all right and we are both live the last
word with ebon sees what is going on
them uh well it's been just as this
wheat these we keep weeks keep stacking
up sorry apparently it's a it's just
more and more shows me that i am not
gonna have enough time to keep up with
all this stuff it is crazy oh yeah I
agree man it is it is so it's so intense
right now in gaming in general with so
many good things out at one time it's
just not enough time in a day right now
you've got to make tough decisions now
so yeah we've got we finished up with
the second beta kind of the open beta
for everyone for anthem last weekend
yeah division because it's a little
farther across the world got its private
beta started literally yesterday so
that's been a thing and we both will
talk about that and then we've also got
destiny 2 coming up with its final
events for season of the forge and then
there's games called like Sakura that I
want to play cuz I have some sauce games
and I'm like oh my god that's number
four it was just all that stuff like
piling on right now and I'm like I'm in
trouble
Oh in trouble right now I don't even
know what to do so I don't know what
about you what where are you feeling
like where do you see yourself you know
a couple months down the road we'll jump
in the best year in just a second but
where do you see yourself headed to like
yeah you know to the most like yeah yeah
I know you know drabs I there you go
it's tough um destiny what I realized
these past two weeks
is even with all these new games
Destiny's still my first love like
there's still that gunplay right there's
still that that unique space magic all
the things I love you know me shout the
power I had a discussion with him
offline and like when a lot of the I
think anthems demo came out in division
and he gets me up and he's like hey man
we're gonna be doing a scorcher II know
you got a spot
all right you want to get down and I'm
like I could we ended up not linking up
but I know where he's at
because I know his first time you just
like I guess for him anthems not for him
but um you know is one of them things
that I'm like ultimately destiny is my
core I will always beat me but gotta be
real you know I'm saying we're in kind
of like the downtime right now you know
we're coming towards the end of black oh
I'm really kind of prepping for you know
season of The Drifter or whatever that
kind of stuff and then you've got ant
them out here and we'll talk about that
in depth you know and looking fantastic
on PC on PC sorry sorry Xbox faithful
I'm not there with you guys on one
console I tried it I in fairness it's
not the same game PC masters I'm just
saying you know baby boxes you send all
your complaints to the cheetah for the
in box but oh yeah man the ninja will
will be on PC with aunt them cuz it is
glorious you know I'm saying but um and
then y'all see the division came out and
it's just like man you know and division
was something I always wanted to love so
you know to me now with all the
refinements all changes so the way it
looks as of right now as of February 8th
division I mean that's always gonna be
my go-to
without me and it is downtime I think
right now it's division early dog makes
the early call it early it's early I
gotta peel the layers off right now
right now I'm in the honeymoon phase
exactly you know I'm saying so it's just
like you know what this you're
everything I wanted you to be the first
time like the first time like oh you
like you as much you know I'm saying but
you had no endgame and then you start to
be shallow than you had glitches bugs
hacks and then you're through right so I
think that's in my people I guess
tonie's gonna definitely survive and
stuff but they gotta come with it now
competitions here anthems here division
is here like whoo we'll get into it but
right as of right now you know I'm
saying graphic gosh out there he's oh he
gonna have to animate that fire yeah I
did I need one of them grab
yeah we're forever yeah if you can have
an infinite loop yeah I'd be great ooh a
be perfect you can hook us up I have
that going on because it's some serious
Luda shooter can't fire a talk going on
right now I tried not to tarnish the
image too much with the text box sorry
blending is there got to get the
background in there I was I was given
Cognito a hilarious light little blip
there cuz I was like he was like he has
like got the image gonna add some text
on there and I'm trying not to copy like
any other podcast or anything so it just
one little like info blip in the corner
and then I was like first I added like
the color blending and then I got the
just the little pieces in there and I'm
like but yeah that's as far as Micra by
photoshop skills go and I'm sitting I'm
like dude I can't draw it cheetahs and
engine fires and I'm like that's why we
have an artist because my talent stopped
real short of the rest of this entire
image so what graphic God first of all I
want to shout out rack of war with the
$2 super chat thank you so much brother
he says PC destroys all any anthem Ram
brood beautifully on his PC I'm with you
brother
I'm which gonna yeah got me on that you
know say shout - screaming yeah graphic
god thank you bro I mean this image if
you get that crackling fire oh why are
we talking we oh yeah we gotta talk we
definitely talk about that but yeah
that's pretty much what I got only three
so the early call I'm kind of in my M -
Machop - M - it's like leaning division
right now but things can change we know
anthems got a lot of stuff to talk about
in Division I mean - thing we're waiting
to see what they gonna do but what about
you if it's in early coal I know have
you touched have you touched much
division or so I got through the two
campaign missions really yeah I got a
pretty good chunk done last night late
stream so I did that did some side
missions a couple control points I'm
like level four five I'm not quite five
I don't think so I'm probably four
pretty much headed right to that dark
zone mission is where I was going next
so that was kind of the kind of the feel
so far I don't wanna get too much into
it right now as for me for what I'm
probably gonna lean as I mean you said
it well to season the drifter we don't
know what's coming
but our suspicions are that this will be
the lightest of the content drops mainly
because timing from previous content
expansions and also you've got just what
is it about it's about The Drifter and
it's about gambit and it does seem like
it is gonna be mostly related to those
two with some quests and some exotics
but it doesn't have the feel of leg you
know four or five pieces of PvE content
even if the four does work similar it's
not this release of those and the quests
for those it's it's just it's like
probably one thing and then maybe these
a little stagger at weekly quests or
something it feels like you might jump
in on Tuesday and knock out your daily
reset and then like whatever else has
called you then you know keep going so
for the feeling of just mixing it up to
kind of a difference for me like anthem
as it comes out first especially I'm
gonna see how long it holds me but I
think that one has my interest piqued
mostly just because it's something that
I I don't know it's the whole Ironman
baby that's literally what ality yeah it
has a different feel like literally
division is like a a flat piece of paper
it is there's not much vertical to it
but I mean no but you're literally
you're on the street I lost you to DC
the one the ones really cool I mean
honestly it does feel New York City is
really really cool but it is like
skyscraper after tall building after
things finish together you're going
through each of these streets and they
have tall buildings on every single
corner so it not every but it was like
most of what you felt in that game was a
lot of taller buildings and stuff just
the fact that when you load launched
into the division beta and you had just
like the greener lush area had a
completely different feel you walk up on
like the the lawn of the White House
apparently we're doing this podcast
completely organized
yeah we're completely out order but it
was just the feel of that was like okay
Division two's definitely bring in a
different feel and the city feel is cool
but for me anthem you literally I jump
jump and I just start flying in the air
and like that's all but that part like
the mobility in that game is almost
cooler to me than even like
I mean destiny is like it's the
in-between you got a little like the
double jumps little space magic but
mantua's flying in the air and hovering
and there's something to that and
there's little pieces we get into it
that still has me a little more excited
division 2 it's like I love division 2
up to a point and that's again we'll see
where it goes
dogs with anthem so for now for now my
my second love second love the destiny
will be probably anthem at least for the
stars
you both have we're gonna put a we both
have side pieces right now yeah which I
mean we're using metaphors by rent right
now but we're gonna watch out with my I
actually have a first love of all my
wife is actually I love my wife cheating
on the yeah the maiden of Destiny so
let's look forward to Owen problem is
it's gonna be tough to do them all or
just I will have no eyelids anymore so
that's fun to its verticality I gotta
give you credit cuz just one last thing
and what you said I wouldn't handle down
people like I think you in combat so in
the same boat because again not to
discredit anything from anthem light
it's it's something new right it's that
verticality it's that Iron Man the game
it's doing something else did it has
some Diablo tones overtones to it so I'm
with you on the newness aspect I can
totally understand while you're leaning
that way for right now and for the
initial you know February 8th last word
you know where we leaned in Canada so I
get it I get it and I like I said both
have their appeal it's gonna be real
good but competition's great man let's
get into what's going on so what's going
on with with destiny right we'll start
off with them first what we doing yep
yes an SD we had a club it's fairly
light but we got some information about
the world of Valentine's Day a little
bit of love action going around in the
air and crimson days is coming back so
quick little side here on crimson days
that starts next week yes now unlike
previous times
it's only a week what do you think about
that just being one week
um I'm okay with it only because let's
be real I mean historically crimson days
has never been a fan favorite like
historically I remember one year maybe I
kissed its debut year you know I played
a lot of shot the Lord Squad I played a
lot with him and we really got into the
mechanic and um you know I just don't
feel it's a mode that again will
deep-diving what's coming this year but
historically in the past I don't ever
felt it was a mode that you kind of deep
dived in like it's you kind of you know
I'm gonna we're gonna set up shop with a
crimson days man like we're gonna bleed
us a like it was just like okay it's
here it's a Valentine's event at least a
vibe for me I don't know like how have
you felt about past crimson days I mean
you're more of a PvP player that I am so
crucibles your wheelhouse me I'm just
like is there an event where I got to do
something y'all spend a little time but
yeah I mean previously it hasn't had
that appeal of here's a new force or
here's a you know the dawning event and
there's a Sparrow to go get that looks
like a slay and you're out there like
shooting a bunch of stuff and baking
cookies and like it has felt Lackland
it's kind of like the not to put a
redheaded color on a but stepchild
events because like it gets pretty
minimal love generally so yeah I was
like it's it's not what I've been like
ooh I can't wait for this to show up I
was like oh be up there it is like and
I'm like and and it's just like not
surprising like I had no expectations at
all and I read what it is and I'm like
sounds about right
you nailed it it's literally crimson
days figuratively is the redheaded
stepchild of it and you know we go see
what I do let's get into what what what
they're doing this year maybe we can
break the Monica all right so crimson
doubles is the 2v2 crucible playlist at
the center of the event combat scenario
is to vie to clash with a round based
twist I don't know what the round base
twister stay in close proximity to your
partner and your abilities will recharge
a faster rate stray too far your enemies
will be given a waypoint leading to your
location which if I read this and pretty
sure it's what it was last year
pretty much yeah I was gonna say do you
does that sound right I was like I feel
like that's what it was
what sure that a whole rage mechanic who
person yes right okay if you can't find
a partner don't worry there will be
matchmaking which is good I can't
remember if they did matchmaking before
or not oh good question
I can't remember yeah I was like because
I feel like I know I feel like not too
but you don't have I don't gotta look
back in the archives flip back in the
book nope skating but it says to sweeten
the butt deal we will be turning on
Valor bonuses throughout the event for
crimson doubles and all of their
crucible modes so basically once you get
done with your crucible then go or your
great your crucible crimson modes then
just go have some fun get yourself some
Valor I guess it's what they're saying
but so it sounds little just like clash
with the twist I don't know if it's just
clash with rounds maybe it's like you
know first of five kills or something
like that who knows and then just have
the ability to recharge by sticking
together so but - but as you go around
the corners people's abilities I I do
finally have kognito on PC so I might we
might have to jump in there with our
stow it our podcast brethren and
basically I'm gonna jump in his backpack
and we're gonna go around this uh this
PvP field so let him fool you this man
is kind of anybody's carry him hopefully
in this new med I'm trashing it except
yeah I was like I know we got that yeah
so I'm in division talk in these pockets
but um since I have come back during the
whole reign of the last word matter it
is rough out here for me I have I found
my footing shout out to Forte he was
with me one day I was getting scraped
but I part of it I was playing as a
specific way to get a lot of quest stuff
done but um yeah it's rough like it's
just that because snipers are good and
the last word is dominant inside and I
don't have it yet I'm still working on
it and um I get all my go tools have not
are not effective anymore like all my
old gold
Jews are not affected we all know what
happens in Telesto so we're gonna get
into that but um yeah it's just my it's
just a different matter I'm not seeing
the Met is bad I'm just saying I'm
terrible in the current meta right now
like I am NOT doing good right now so I
gotta get my hands on last word so
basically this is all leading back to
crimson doubles which is not just will
be carrying me on my way figure out a
good you go mad at econo the only thing
that's been saving me which is weird is
that stupid
what is it the hanging nail the ringing
in it one of those arm ringing yeah the
auto-rifle it really no from the forge
ever reason I still can't call it I know
auto rifles got a slight buff but I
guess it's the range that is the only
thing that I'm feeling semi I don't
using that chaperone that's that's the
only thing I'm able to kind of hold my
own a little but I'm not I haven't been
on shrieks Nova walks nerf that killed
me so now I got to change my mess up
right now man I'm not doing good
literally Telesto Nova warping you just
got shot twice yeah my whole build got
nerfed into the ground Bungie came for
me so yeah yeah that's where I am right
now all right my rant so am i complete
no no you're good like I jumped into PC
you it is very true especially while
people are still working on last word
you see the people that have the gun yes
and you see the people that are trying
to get the gun and there's a predator I
wish there were two different like
matchmaking playlists because a few
games don't play differently and when
those people are in the same match one
is getting screwed and the other ones
like yeah yeah because I mean when you
go for that quest and you don't want to
die too much you have to play so
conservative like I mean some people
that didn't make him which is gone now
so that wasn't even an option just if
you played you know safer with some
supers that you can just chunk out there
here's my sidebar by the way may him a
lot of fire stuff oh my god oh no it's
the shards gallon or blood garage
I had a clip because I was where
I think my last word quest video and
there was a point I was going back
through footage I was like oh what am I
saying here and it's a clip where I get
killed by a guy with the shards and he
goes blade brush I spawn kind of come
around same dude not too far away so
setting up real good here three set
about five seconds later same super same
dude I watched the feed and then I just
go on a little farther on the corner the
guy keeps running runs into me again the
same dude same sir / three same guy
three supers like 20 second one I'm not
actually making it up it was I looked
back I was like it's probably less time
than that whenever your spawn time is is
how long he had it back and I'm just
like I know my supers up a lot in that
mode but I can't just like kill a guy
throw it kill a guy throw it kill a guy
throw it kill a guy throw there's not
looking an infinite loop for me so that
super with shards and especially mayhem
is really really broken bad level
I mean Golden Gun you saw that more if
they had some people to shoot it felt
like that thing was just continually
going which Golden Gun for PvE I mean
that was cool love and you know it's
gonna have a bit more use but oh man
that blade brush I didn't really see a
lot of people killing themselves with it
either so that didn't do that much yeah
and I'm which am a shout to scream he
said he's been wrecking he said the
snipers can't handle it and it's decent
at close range now I feel you man he's
been he's been reckoned with mighty he
says off that's actually I haven't
really tried Scouts really in PvP so I'm
gonna give that a shot definitely yeah
scouts are a thing I've seen more auto
rifles comeback like they're they're
trying to get things in a good spot as
least as good as they can as always
yeah little 2v2 apparently we're just
gonna sit in the corner in the fetal
position wait for it from shoot us cuz
if we ran each other's back back then
that's just the whole problem it's good
but yeah apparently crimson doubles
gonna be a blast for you and I that
being said we've got a new weapon coming
mm-hmm so we'll get to that in a second
but you'll start out by speaking with
lord shaxx he'll give you the fire of
the crimson days emblem so just jump in
and get your emblem
he'll have five crimson bounties for
dailies and then one weekly which is
this this you'll definitely be jumping
in with me
there are four daily bounties and one
weekly bounty which calls you to do a
duo nightfall Wow
check that out okay okay so without one
in the in the discussion of backpacks
you know I'll claim it there but I mean
yeah thank you you guys hey you're the
soloist I'm right you can just like boot
up the mission and just like put a
little bot on your mouth so it keeps
moving and then grab a snack and I'll
come back and be like hey we're ready
shadow go afk yeah pretty much looks
like we've got a ghost we've got an
exotic Sparrow with you know the rose
petals on it we have do have the bow
which we will talk about we have a ward
cliff coil ornament which is very
specific interesting you and then one
emote so those are things that wars will
be able to get from shacks and this is
it so you know I'm gonna intro this and
then I can't want to get your thoughts
on kind of a topic of itself let's go so
similar to horror story last year in
Festival lost we had a specific gun for
specific event now that one was festival
loss was three weeks lasted a while and
it was a max power weapon for everyone
which is cool 600 power level helping
people get some excellent leader in
theory this time around ash X will be
offering a new boat called the valve it
is a solar bow it's at 650 power level
so again that final push for people
trying to get to max level yeah but it's
a week so what I want to ask you is what
do you think of like be the time limited
nature of this weapon if you didn't get
the rabo this is your first solar bow
like the very limited nature around
something that kind of rounds out a very
important piece to a lot of people's
worlds I don't exactly what's going on
here this is anthem and division are
here get your behinds in this game I'm
telling ya right no disrespect this
because I've never seen them usually
yeah it's about a two week to three week
period right we had horror story and you
know all that other stuff this is I mean
in there the
Vince you know even though you know we
know the competition's out there you
know crimson days has it been like I
said the greatest a fan hasn't been
received the greatest so glad they have
that that bowl you know I'm definitely
try to ground and get it but um in my
opinion having a one-week window to do
this is hey we need you engaging in our
like this is how to be honest what you
eat and I'm glad you brought this up
because this is how I envisioned it for
the next couple of months because we
were in between right we're in between
the season of Jeff don't we still don't
know what's going on and to me they
already kind of set the trend with the
last word quest launching that week you
know I'm saying with anthems demo like
they seem to bungees t marketing team
seems to always conveniently drop these
kind of things right around the launch
time of certain games this might be this
is my observation you're allowed to have
an opinion this is hey we see the vision
out there you guys been over there
cheating get your buns in here get this
Bo 650 you know one week you know get in
get out and keep this engagement going
it's almost like this is um hey remember
me moment that's how I look at these
kind of things what are you doing with
aboutabout am I going too hard on them
what do you feel about this whole like
one-week business so mine's not even as
much though like I mean yeah timing wise
they seem to have this stuff pretty
close to the other games I mean they
have to pick weekends at some point
literally it's been every weekend
something's going on so that's just
gonna be hit or miss but they have timed
it pretty well so far give them that yes
but for me it's more the idea of you've
got our Civic bite and you've got subtle
calamity as your general legendary O's
ones arc one solar now there is
technically a bow in last wish that is
solar it's the tyranny of yes uni of
heaven but I don't have that one yet
yes because I've only done so many last
wishes haven't been lucky to get that
drop so it's been its own thing this is
the first time to actually get a solar
bow and you get a chance to get it for a
week yeah so mine is just a limited
nature of leg you know there's always
those moments where if you're out of
town and missing and I wish you pick
like if you're out of town and you don't
have the chance I understand the limited
nature but then it should just be like
hey this is in the loop pool afterwards
like this is your like thunderlord that
was I mean while it sucks that not
everybody has the chance to run to do a
quest to go get it which I still think
that should probably be there right at
least they have a chance to still get
the gun and that kind of have to that
guns broken so you have to have it but
it is I mean I'll go do like I literally
ran shout out to my twitch chat because
they were joining me for a while one
night and I was doing my run through a
strange terrain but I was trying not to
use I didn't use my go figure which for
one was crazy I didn't use thunderlord
and I didn't go arks engine that's like
that would be a normal build on that run
so I went like boy didn't got my face
melted by an ogre a lot but when I was
stepping outside my own meadow and I was
just like trying to do something
different same thing here it's like I
want to do something different it'd be
nice just to have the option for to drop
somewhere that's kind of my thing is
like timing otherwise I just wish the
gun was available all the time
afterwards just at least in the orangey
pool so if people kept playing they
would eventually see it not just like
because I mean it's it's a solar bowl
there's only like one other one it's not
just like an auto rifle it's kind of
limited it's a good point and it's
interesting to see how they handle it
because it also kind of eerily reminds
me of faction rally there's you know
there's people that still never got a
chance to get certain catalysts like I
never got a chance to get SunShot
catalysts and you know what's the option
now we did just recently hear they plan
on adding last twelve they're gonna add
a lot of these exotic catalysts back
into the loophole but again stuff like
this what about guys who like me again
who came to PC who don't have horror
stories on PC right I'm never gonna get
that good like yeah it's tough you know
how do you handle that and one
adjustment that I like that they made is
with the pinnacle weapons for crucible
mm-hmm which is a
yeah which is now it's like okay I don't
have to do the five resets and then in
one season it can still you know carry
over grandfather over that kind of stuff
is cool you know it they're gonna have
to come up with a way because let's just
say this thing I mean we don't know the
stats on this thing what is it the vial
right it's got a vial now you know we
don't know sure not crazy but yeah we
never know what if there's really you
know what if it's really strong you know
yeah we got to see we got to see but if
it is good if it's above average you
know that's that's a definite advantage
so how can people you know who missed
this week you're out of town and week
how can they get that so we shall see
how they handle moving forward yeah it's
just the little bit of nature of like
orangey stuff in the first place if
people want something a grand for don't
take it away yes doesn't seem to like
add it to a quest cool and then add it
to the world if you miss it but I mean
that's what I was like I know
thunderlord's not optimal because
actually they're missing out on the
quest we'll take that idea of like it's
out there now in the world and just you
that would handle things a lot better so
this is your boat in action jumping
around it's got the nice little I'm sure
we'll have like a pink ornament or
something like that on there absolutely
and we'll be the first bow available to
all players of destiny
so if you don't have a forsaken you
never got a bow right correct so this is
the first time and another reason why
I'm like really don't don't take it away
yeah that's good boy we'll see we'll see
gotta get out there you gotta get your
trimmers and days on if you want it if
you're down if you're in town if you're
playing if you're not distracted by 17
other things exactly in other games yeah
it's crazy down right now
but wobbling crimson doubles you'll be
earning seven confectionery hearts with
every win but for every loss and each
daily bounty will roll or do 15 hearts
and the weekly nightfall duo bounty will
give you 75 so that one's actually
probably gonna get done a lot more than
they expect yeah because the things that
you can buy are worth the following
hearts now as this is only a week and
you have a loss
say you're a solo player you can match
make into the crucible section so you
get that bow if that's the only thing
you want is 20 matches of crucible now
if you win you'll get some but to get
the legendary bow that's 20 matches of
crucible and if it costs like 20 and
then you're back down to 0 you're trying
to forklift coil ornament that's 125
like it's not like you're adding it's
not like you're collecting a certain
number it's like hey urn this mini and
you unlock this no it's earned this mini
buy it and start over if I'm really
which it's a lot it's a lot that's a lot
it's definitely a commitment
thus the knight fold will bounce he will
be used well big time 75 yeah I'm
linking up with you on that I'll be
putting out all the solo videos that
Tuesday yeah so you've got the teres
Strela see if I can butcher that word I
thought you came out okay that one's 45
you've got the undeterred exotic sparrow
that's 50 the bow will be a hundred Lord
cliff coil ornament 125 a flaunting
dance legend area moat 150 and then the
warm-hearted gift packages is 15 so it
says if you're looking to spend your
extra hearts checks will be also
offering warm hearted gift packages that
will give you a chance to receive
enhancement course weapons mods gear and
resources taste enhance my course I
think they got enhancement cores in
there oh let's go shout out to this
that's what I'm talking about cuz I miss
ain't gonna lie I miss me some Evo I
miss me some even right now we used to
use the Easy Bake Oven and she would
just be oh me I need these cause I need
to max out some guns yeah so alright
yeah that's some incentive for me right
there literally I think I'm more excited
to be honest because I'm bad y'all like
I'm terrible with my core management
like I'm always infusing I'm always and
keeping multiple bills for different
subclasses I mean my minutia with you
know certain mid maxing of certain play
styles is crazy so I'm they'll run
through core guy I'm the guy that's
logging in just to see spider you know
what it's down to 10 you
shards I'm that guy getting bills uh
what you call about he's done the ones
when you break them up yeah I'm describe
her bounty guy I literally that's me so
you actually have something sentence now
I'm glad I didn't catch that I'm glad
you brought that up now all about them
court you get you guys got any more of
those courses man that is me yes a
little extra incentive to it which is
good because that's some of the stuff
they need do I think those cores and
montt components are in like the proper
spot probably not still but they do keep
putting them in more of these places
which is I don't know it's like a weird
incentive to be like hey come play our
game it will get you these cores we get
we got him we got them on sale right now
like it's a it's a weird incentive to
throw in there when so many people are
still worked about the idea of infusion
yes I heard is not like on the table to
change right now and stuff like that so
they said that's not all along with
these rewards there will be a set of
crimson days triumphs for you to
complete we don't want to spoil all the
treats and reveal the triumphs just yet
but they will reveal these the reward
for completing them all which I'm like
really you're gonna keep something
secret but if you get them all this is
what you get interesting that seems like
the wrong order like hey if you do the
first one hears this mm-hmm
no this is like the completion one you
get your sugary go shell so it actually
looks like I mean it looks like a
chocolate ghost looking shocked yeah mmm
which for me go shells don't do that
much for me I'm sorry I've never really
been a fan of the crimson days like go
shows to be honest I'm just like
whatever
even a shame I never really liked
acrimony I want to see what the shade is
really look like when applied I like it
how it looks on the vow the bowl looks
lit with the shade of yeah I want to see
how like the the other you know how they
are the things kind of look on other
outfits and stuff Lucy so that is like
that like I mean that's your in-game
like do I care about a Crimson Ghost
probably not it's gonna like keep me
that's not gonna be the thing that keeps
me grinding of her triumphs are
finishing you know so many matches or
whatever it takes to get this thing I'm
like if I don't get it I'm like woo
yeah I mean that's just honest because
like you look how many go shells do I
have that I really only care about the
perks and if it pulls up it's like I see
the projection on the go shell more than
I see the ghost now because they see
those sitting around tower when people
are doing stuff yeah but I don't see the
ghost it's too small I agree I agree
it's not that big of an incentive let's
go yeah so little uh a light event you
know spend your time do your nightfall
get your 75 do a few matches get your
bow and that might be what some people
do because that's the only real
exclusive for me that's probably got the
incentive for me I agree I agree but yep
so double drops are back which is good
they have a fix I mean they have not
gone back to the festival the cost they
just like get all the drops you can your
go good so you're gonna have a crimson
Ingram with every bright in gram they
will also be available sir silver if you
want to but I wouldn't like play enough
you'll probably get what you want
nothing in here is too crucial constants
the Engram have not changed so if you
didn't get anything you wanted last year
or new to Disney this is your chance to
get more so it looks like you got the
ornament for sweet business I first I
can't quite make out the other two okay
the third one number three is a graviton
okay that one yeah makes more sense is
that look so yeah anyway a couple gun
ornaments
you've got our maybe cold heart that
might be it it's just that weird like
little like handle thing yeah this
little handle thing with like a bathtub
stopper on the side it looks like just
an old school like this little bad thumb
stopper with a string just it's kind of
a gun I don't know what that god is
though it's weird but I mean you have
like here's like four variations ago
shells whoo here's like four sparrows
well I mean I'm sorry but like Ian's
especially watch all these drive at 150
and I'm just gonna dismantle them anyway
they're gonna be 150 with like weapon
reloading like nope and nope like you're
out you're gone
others and desperate tabs
[Laughter]
it's just one of the yeah so most of
this is like I just go I just literally
want the bow that's all I want from this
whole event and for me it's I know it's
a lackluster event for them and they do
it for one week so it's like gonna
hopefully be a quick grind yeah
but everything else for this if you
maybe want an emo check and see what the
prismatic facet has and stuff like that
but all in all not much here so late
indeed there's kind of a cool bow the
tiny bow emote so that one's actually
kind of cool kind of like a little Cupid
thing so that one's not bad that will be
a direct purchase from ever verse I
think so usually their little bundle
thing they've got so if you want to want
to get it for some dinero you can spend
some money you can splurge know how it
looks yeah so it'll be next week
February 22nd don't include on weekly
resets on you know the week after so you
get a week find your buddy it's been
some time in crucible and get yourself a
bow they do have some more buzzer words
out there so it looks like they've got a
hoodie it is actually a zip so kind of
cool-looking but I don't think it's
really speaking to me it's not if this
was the feet if this the thunderlord
thing looked like this
baby I would I would jump on that I
didn't keep putting the hot stuff with
long sleeves and you know saying like
they needed to put either that with a
hoodie or shirt like in niggles cars but
um yeah like I'm running out in that
that's not that's not a goal for me yeah
let me put the the hearts are the the
roses on my back they're really not my
thing so I mean they're usually I bet
it's real comfortable though I can tell
you that most of the bungee stuff bungee
store stuff I have purchased has been
good quality so I don't mind wearing all
my t-shirts around or more in the gay
King of Spades one right now so that's
that's the one my dad got that one too
no so that's basically criminalized or
PvP for a little bit
do your nightfall do a couple match made
matches at least get your bow see what
happens after that
actly boom and they will have a bungee
bounty that's gonna be Thursday February
14th from 11:00 a.m. to 1:00 p.m. so a
couple hours middle of the day if you
want to go hunt down some of the bungee
folks see even get your you know
specific emblem from taking them out but
it will be twos so if you're playing
against you know like Cosmo and Dylan
good luck unless you're just a beast
those guys definitely have their stuff
together so mm-hmm
and we get on to another big topic for
the world of titans now this is
something I've never done but it's
something many people on PC do because
I've watched too many videos - no it's
not done Titan skating actually going to
get a decent fix I don't know if it's
gonna be fully removed but I definitely
think they're gonna fix the macro effect
of it if some of you guys have never
done this basically all it is is like
people can like map a macro to their
mouse wheel so if they like scroll up
and makes them basically do a whole
bunch of inputs all at the same time
really fast and it's a way for them to
gain weight to achieve even if you ever
seen somebody like like the legend
himself he'll you'll I've watched him do
it in a video just like goofing around
and he'll cover ground in a map plate
just start that momentum going faster
and faster they go so fast they smash
into a wall like you get enough momentum
you get that horizontal smash so the
what that does is it generally breaks
things like PvP like control points I
mean what do you think about Titans
gaming since you're literally just a
wart like our luck mean Oh ever since I
can it be a PC I haven't got smacked by
so many Titans it's ridiculous yeah it's
it's it's out of control it's out
especially if I see PvP um yeah it
needed to happen it definitely need to
happen um you know you guys were living
your best life for some time now and you
know it's time to kind of rein it all in
it started to get you in line with
everything's who are we gonna up bungees
thought process behind this sure so
later this month we're fixing the issue
with the Titan lifts ability so it's
literally just something with the jump
that they program that they were having
an issue
fixing without breaking they didn't want
to like ruin the jump for the Titan so
they apparently took a while to fix yes
oh no no go ahead no that's literally
all gonna say oh just like this actually
did take a while because they've been
talking about like yeah we're gonna do
it but we don't want to break it so yeah
no you're right continue I mean it's
been around since basically it launched
on PC for like your one right like it
was pretty early on mm-hmm so a year in
the making basically much so it will
still be possible to maximize your lift
speed by skillfully timing your lift
activation inputs to boost your overall
momentum in other words Titan skating is
still possible just less excessive I
guess well that's why I was like it's
kind of fixed but I'm not sure if it
just can't be Mack Road maybe that's
kind of the idea yeah but some of you
may be asking why this is being
addressed players utilizing these
unconventional methods are effectively
able to exceed the bounds of expected
Guardian movement speeds so drastically
it creates an unfair advantage so like
getting to control pinpoints if it's
like iron banner like if you get there
faster you've got that advantage so I
mean that's a big thing but they also
say like you can you know it's harder to
aim position but also even like
networking tor apparently it's almost
like flag yeah so it is to a point of
breaking the game so they want them to
be kind of back in check so they said
they'd rather continue to build on the
Titan to identify the fast-moving
aggressive jetpack warrior so they
wanted to like not break the jump which
was important then one of the abilities
to still be fun but they don't want you
guys to like just ruin the game for
people I mean Titan skating is a thing
so now granted we have Titan skating you
guys have like Nova warp and blade brush
so in the grand scheme of things it's no
I don't I know I don't know if we still
win and I definitely don't know yeah
they like they nerfed your whole world
so that's fair yes you lost Telesto you
lost your Nova warp and you're like I I
have to go back to grade school I have
to start from scratch without yeah and I
think it's gonna have to be dawn blade
for me right now I have to go back to
Don blade based on how long super lasts
and in the movement there and yeah
it's tough man it's tough but also you
know Cataclysm still pretty strong I
just gotta get my skull man don't let us
throw a very strong I'm just waiting for
you to give me the word
when oh you put a better video and you
say oh he's got the skull that's all i
we have I waiting for that text
she's got disco when you I am logging in
with a quickness that I miss my skull of
dire armored car man oh so badly I used
to be my um my escalation protocol go to
and maybe I can yeah yeah so good and
now with the new meta you know in PvP I
really want to get into it but it's like
so I that that's my exotic that I really
missed for that for that top tree yeah I
pulled it out of the vault the other day
just when I was trying that void run and
I didn't use it as much just because I'm
I'm horrible at using my super in the
first place which is just my own thing
and I like end up shooting everything
which is definitely an issue for the
people who watched it live but there was
one yeah I fired it it tracked and then
like a couple more and I was like it was
almost back I'm like yeah that's still
damn good so but Cataclysm hits like a
truck now on in PvE
oh my god it it hits really really hard
I mean you'll run around it just like
one shot stuff that normally you're
going oh this is this is faster turn I
lose you
oh my bad I had immediate and I was like
yeah like it oh you're super energy back
yeah it's like it's it's kind of nuts so
ya know when you get that thing you'll
be living the warlock Cataclysm life
again
but yeah rng has not been kind to you on
that one just waiting a little bit more
reading material from the people at
Bungie I definitely want these two so
we've got
so that's pretty much it for exciting
skating so that wraps that up we've got
the grimoire anthology number two which
first one was awesome did you get it and
read it or did you pick it up way
through yeah
way through it's nice I'ma be honest
though like it's a was it a lot of it I
thought it was a lot of like the book of
sorrow stuff and yeah that's why I'm
curious what this will be because that
one seemed very very hive focused yeah
yeah thrown off because not that I hate
it I like it I didn't think it was just
going to be Brooklyn I was going to get
more stuff like you know so I'm dying to
know if what this focus is gonna be on
anthology number two and and surprise by
with the second thing you're about to
mention which is the comic collection
mmm come and so you know I get to see my
boy in all its gory our Lord and Savior
mister Osiris man
well that's known and we just got done
dirty with a bad dlc yeah I was
definitely his fault but yeah I mean
honestly they both look pretty cool like
I don't know the grimoire the ancho
anthology like there's so much stuff
again it is lore outside of the game so
there's that little like stab in the
back smidge but no they're just they're
fun to read they're put together very
well the art in them is really good the
comics have been cool they said there's
gonna be some exclusive stuff in these
so but I think I'm with you I want to
know what the heck this like the
anthology volume 2 I don't know what's
like the stor story like what are they
covering yeah well what's the focus very
they just literally printed out all the
pages of pipes video about the last word
and that's what's in here - and I have a
wife audiobook there you go that's what
I mean that's what I need I need this in
audio form and wife as the narrator I'm
good in so the comic collection 144 page
valium includes the comic collection
Plus never-before-seen stories behind
the scenes exclusive stuff from the
artist and volume 2 they don't really
say so I have no idea what its gonna
talk about so we will see on that couple
patch fixes on breaking the mold this is
one I do want to mention says since
mid-january destiny player support is
monitored an issue where the blacker
murky mold is available from 801 only on
a player's first character let you go
pick it up on so
pursuit is a required item to Ernie is
ignite his birding and some players have
become blocked from unlocking this
weapon from the character of choice so
with the update to point 2.0 which they
say early March seasons The Drifter
mm-hmm we don't have a date yet but
we'll see that we'll be getting fixed so
finally a date it just took basically it
took all of season of blitzie of the
forge to fix that thing that's been
broken in it which kind of sucks but you
know mmm yeah that's kind of the only
main one crimson days as a couple things
where they've guts I think you just have
to complete the red war campaign and be
level 20 outside of that pretty simple
stuff mm-hmm-hmm
speaking of byph shout out to him as
well the last word and more incomplete
story movie of the week I this is this
is literally a movie by the way max have
you watched it I started it I gotta
finish it I mean just like literally set
down time and grab some popcorn yeah I
love shuttle we got let's give five some
credit in the community right and um
this guy's been doing it for a long time
you know he's got the silky smooth
campfire voice just like you know for
like our image and that's where like
he's the person that you want to sit
down and just listen to him talk well
because not only is he knowledgeable but
it's just so well produced and he gets
you in the spirit of whatever the Lord
is right so whatever the story he's
telling he gets you in pocket man shot
the Oise yeah by video just by fizz
another level and um like I said shout
out the arm hair myelin games all or
guys you know for them to put that as a
movie of the week is is huge but what I
also what I'm hoping is that we know
what the first Bungie arm what was it
called the community thing when they
brought the community guys now some
atomic re so we know the first summit
they brought myelin and no disrespect to
my that's the best my guy I love my life
but I was also surprised that both of
them worked down there right cuz boy he
is synonymous with lore so what I'm
hoping is for a whole
sumit number two whatever they got
planned you know maybe he's involved
with anthology two we don't even know
because I know Milan Gaines was involved
with my uh with anthology one so let's
get by Finn there let's get him his due
he he has such a passion for this stuff
and it's good to see him recognize so
shot the wife met him one time good dude
very tall yeah tall dude like what six
to three you like medium you're like oh
oh 511 but cool dude Machado those - out
the present squad hopefully I get chance
to link up with these guys at Guardian
con as well as my fan boy for my boy
unknown Plato those are my dudes man I
really like present school shout out to
them and yeah yeah definitely check this
thing out if you haven't seen it we all
know last word and thorn is one of the
more iconic weapon loss stories in all
of destiny we see it with the last word
quests what's going on how they paying
homage to it and to see by through this
the whole dredgen yor the whole you know
shin malphur all of that good stuff
hottest now he's gonna tie in with the
drifter and you know he's pissed after
what we did but uh that's the another
spoiler spoiler but um yeah man this is
good stuff check this out really quality
stuff yeah so yeah it's like an hour and
26 minutes it's really well done if you
ever wanted to dive in and see if you
have an interest in destiny lore here
here's where you go his other one where
he did the full like destiny one -
destiny - thing that one but he I think
he had a million views on that recently
no yeah million views are a million
likes some insane number like I think he
had the views easy but I think he got
like a million likes on it which was
amazing so it was solo yeah so shout out
some I've definitely well deserved here
I mean the time put in the this is
insane it's an hour and a half the art
the voiceovers they had some cool people
from the community helped out really
really really cool stuff so dope and
apparently people have been having fun
with Argos lately as well a pair of
people doing like solo I know carrot
karolina gaming in the air line of
gaming I know that guy solo tat recently
I saw him on Twitter
messin with swords and Argos so
something's like old raid challenges
people have been doing definitely
keeping the community busy especially
with the new meta as it is you got a
curious running around being no man that
yeah oh it's dirty to stuff because with
all these buck these buffs now you're
going into these old Ray's and just you
know we already saw that the golden guns
at it would callous and it's so the new
meta has definitely made the old content
a little more refreshing and how strong
we feel now and I like stuff like that I
miss what we used to do back in d1 you
know what is it a legends of triumph
when you go back into these old Ray's
and you're using newer strategies
because you know different things that I
met it got buffed and it's fun stuff so
it's good to see you know community come
up with kind of things like that makes
you makes you feel powerful I like going
back to the old content and feeling
powerful like that's something I've
always enjoyed so shout out these guys
running around so it's breaking up our
gules yeah that's been weird so that's
like that's one of those like me as a
solo player only like nine Falls had my
you know shattered thrown over the
weekend stuff like that was really fun
put me in some of those like raid
encounters there is such a small margin
of error on some of that stuff it's
impressive to watch so they had a couple
little like pieces of art but they just
they're keeping it quiet right now
they just said crimson day is coming up
they don't have much on season The
Drifter I'm honestly sure that it's
gonna be after because I mean date wise
we've got so we've got season our
crimson day is gonna be 12 to 19th
yes and then I'm guessing our 21st
podcast or no 22nd flashpoint on
February 22nd which is anthem day by the
way
is gonna be hopefully where they drop
the news on season The Drifter so
because it's gonna be a week it's
probably gonna be the fifth you see my
guess is March 5th so you've got a week
or two to start getting it out there so
not long not long for the first season
of the forge and we'll see if this
drifter season has anything to offer but
that's
a pretty quiet week in the world the
destiny we talk more than I even thought
we would yeah actually we do yeah pretty
quiet week I mean we know listen listen
destiny friends we're in the incubation
phase we got out we got a hull up you
know you know you get your stuff done
you jump in you did your little crimson
days but there's other stuff to play and
that's okay that's okay we got things to
do you know I'm saying but i guarante up
you best believe and I'm very curious to
see I don't know I don't know if I
actually I wouldn't say that I'm very
curious to see a non-active vision
focused Bungie but I'm not gonna give
that title yet until we see the
September deal see because then in my
opinion that's truly them well that's
with the shackles off right because we
know they have to see this thing
throughout all the way through season
adrift then what is it a season of the
redacted season of the play robot ninja
season like Python nobody knows like I
think so much in that picture but I've
no idea oh I feel until September we're
gonna have some fun with wiggler without
what-you-call-it season a drifter lure
wise especially Thor and wise especially
we know stuff's coming you know that
kind of thing so that's gonna be fun
lure watch see how things continue but I
am definitely curious what are they
gonna do for September like how they
coming out because you know that's gonna
be against the wall and this is gonna be
all them and I'm excited I don't we call
it a back against the wall I call it I'm
excited you know and I'm saying to see
what they have cooking you know for
themselves so what do you feel you know
winding down now what uh
sort of say winding down but with the
remaining content for destiny like how
you how you feeling
I mean for me it's to a point of I think
you're right it's just gonna be right
now with everything else we've got going
I mean there's three other games they're
gonna have a lot to talk about
I mean - and then stuff like Sakura and
stuff like that like there's gonna be
things that like pull it my time so if
it is smaller things where hey I'd knock
out last word on maybe Tuesday or
Wednesday if they ever throw another
dungeon in there that'd be awesome but
that might be the type of thing that I
get to look forward to yeah that's you I
mean they're they're just so fun
is it is what yeah like that definitely
is the next big chunk is what I'm
waiting for us well the Annual Pass like
for 35 bucks I mean I've got my share
content what I have somebody else buy it
you know I mean I feel like there are
certain things they might have missed if
they didn't do the annual pass because
it's just not like you're not in the
moment as much and going back through
and be like hey grind through the forges
are you really gonna grind through the
forges at like 700 or go through your
rolls I mean there's certain things it's
I have a weird I have no idea how I feel
about the end you'll pass yeah I guess
we'll see when it ends up but yeah I
mean I've been on phone without now that
I've been more like Forge 2 or 4th
Street I would actually have fun with
the fortress I really now started
getting to the mechanic stuff like that
I did uh what's it what's this now
you'll be labs one I can't pronounce it
with the beef burgers eeeh
yeah I did burgers eeeh had fun with
that you know it's cool but again did
like shot elbow get it right now we're
in the hibernation stage they've got to
gear up and see we got to see what
they've got cooking you know I'm not
gonna get crazy for The Drifter in a
sense that I'm not gonna tell destined
fans y'all drifters here now you're
gonna stop playing everything else I
don't envision that I I'm keeping my
expectations very low because again
that's part of the annual past my model
and that was the activision you know
finishing out the contract phase is what
I'm calling it yeah so keep expectations
in check it could be great I'm not
saying it's not we also know there's no
raid right so okay right now yep no red
alright
and that redacted ad looks a little bit
sad about that but you know we'll see
towards the end of the year
what happened September is where I'm
getting excited September I want to see
what they do at e3 what they have 2:08 a
minute Sony's not at e3 hmm how do they
present
he's enough September like I'd say
bigger question is do you think they are
actually glued to September they gotta
do something because and I mean let's
let's talk about it right um we know
what was it February when's anthems
release cuz we're that's the next one it
ever 22nd yeah 22nd right then we have
March 20 whatever for
fifteen right March 15 there you go
thanks for the correction it doesn't you
know um you know yeah they'll have their
seasons out but um we again we don't we
don't know what that's gonna be
and based on what we see for both games
both games are planning to continue
content so yeah they gonna need to
really come to even if it's not the
traditional September release cadence
that they've followed in the past with
uh with um with Activision you can't
wait until October November
you know the battlefields and the Call
of Duty's are coming you know part of me
thinks they have to stick to that
September cadence that's just me
but what do you think I was like this is
just their first time to like breathe
and think on their own and make a
decision to be like are we forced to put
anything up no there's no schedule
there's no publisher saying hey heller i
water whether it's finished or not like
put something out there now what i hope
that there's something there absolutely
it's the perfect time for destiny as you
said before that stuff it has there it's
been their place in the you know cadence
of a calendar year and all those things
do fit my question is if this is their
time to pull back maybe do another
annual pass and not do something as big
and maybe it'll be a fall off and then
see destiny three if they really get
their time to focus without being like
hey let me smash something out right
kind of for September and take away from
development on what could be d3 or
destiny to in word for like forsaken
type situation like maybe in 2020 on
future generations because they have to
be looking towards 2020 for ps5 for Xbox
to whatever they call it all of those
things are a thing because having a
launch around those costs in both
platforms being that big new game trying
to take advantage of the new hardware
running 60 frames per second and all of
those things are a huge piece of
whatever their next big release is gonna
be the question is how much do they
focus on that yeah I think you know that
I think that's the other factor as well
because we are literally at the end of
current console generation we all know
for the most part you know if you guys
are listening I know what's pocket you
know you know I mean is when these
systems are coming for the console guys
you know we're getting anaconda aka
Scarlett or whatever the new Xbox is you
know I'm saying whatever whatever song
it's a tie to that's five which is
definitely coming and definitely with
backward compatibility you know I mean
all of that huge library of great games
so these systems the only thing that's
really been holding them back has been
CPU performance so that's the sixty
frames per second we all intend to see
you know higher CPUs a little bit better
GPUs so these systems are gonna be able
to rock you know finally and be kind of
somewhat on par for what's going on with
PC and um I think with d3 we've all
known based on shout out to hold law and
some guys I've had on iron law podcast
you know with the abolishment of the
Activision deal you know that now sets
up the whole exclusive thing most likely
fair player whoever wants to buy it if
it's a playstation who wants to buy it
again every up if it's Xbox wants to
jump in but at some point like you said
he cross plane cross progression is now
the new wave everybody starting to talk
about it you're hearing games like
titanfall you're hearing other games
you're hearing on the obviously
fortnight was to trendsetter you don't
I'm saying like games now are putting
that in mind you know and Eckstein has
been that game that has been suffering
without it belongs and it's probably the
most beneficial to have it you know from
an engagement standpoint and gonna have
lower lobbies you know on PC and
crucible on whatever platform and even
if they don't do the cross play cross
progression is huge
being able to play on the format you
want and continue your Guardian huge and
again that's gonna be set up for um in
my opinion for the next generation of
consoles so you know they've got a they
have a bunch of opportunities they they
could just kind of stay in hard
hibernation and and just you know push
out maybe one content update later this
year then fall back and then all you
know guns blazing 2020 new hardware you
know and that could be d3 on
we got to see man this is a very this is
a very I don't I'm we choose my words
kept its it's not critical like it's
life or death but they do have some
important decisions they have to make
you know so that's that's what I got on
it what you got on it before we get into
these other two games uh I mean crit
buff said it pretty well too
for the one big thing has been at least
about d1 and what feels like carried
forward is their engine their their
agility to make quicker decisions
ya know know that help both chats right
now the last thing literally just
mentioned the engine like yours and line
this is great you guys are you guys are
on point cuz that's yeah that's the one
big one that engine from d1 taking the
eight hours loading time from the Jason
try article was like I open be like wow
that is so awful and if any of that
stuff has come forward which it still
feels like some of its kind of tacked
and they're like I mean the PC port and
stuff came over really smooth but
whatever that whole engine they have is
some they need to take their systems and
be able to work with them better
everything so LinkedIn tight cuz you've
got mmm like anthem feels even my was
talking my brother about this
everything's feels more
compartmentalised and like you can just
like you can like stick a Lego brick on
the side and add something to that for
destiny to it feels like you have to
throw the jigsaw puzzle piece up in the
air again and try and put put it back
together it doesn't feel as quickly
adaptive so if they can make that fix
and there's and that's another one he's
like you know and put out something
smaller I don't know if that Nettie's
infusion of a hundred million could keep
you afloat for a year while they do
little stuff here and there and then do
something along the lines of a bigger
police but yeah they can take d3 and
make it you know just better in every
way like fix that net code that all that
stuff just so many things I have one
concern though on the PC side and again
remember these pluses and minuses of
them leaving Activision one - in my
opinion let's give credit where credit
is due
vicarious did an amazing PC port they
didn't I love this PC port like it is
one of the best ports in my opinion like
ever for game and um that's not going to
be there with the next
duration so again this is gonna be on
bungee or who they potentially outsource
it out to you know and I'm a little
concerned I'm not gonna because listen
man battlenet say what you want that
listen man that PC port is so silky
field-of-view 60 frames to all you your
settings when you rock an ultra it is
gorgeous and I just want that level of
quality you know moving forward when it
comes to d3 so I'm just being honest I'm
being honest I need that level you have
to maintain that level so I don't know
if you got a snatch up and hire some
five you know ex vicarious vision people
keep that standard
I know Nova said I'm a little worried
you're not concerned bit that's a great
point man that was under there under
Activision's
tutelage so you know we just got to see
just got see yeah I mean Bungie signed
off on the product but man if they put
out a damn good one
so fax but yeah so I mean Dusty's got a
lot it's still future's up in the air
III may or may not say a lot I mean
that's kind of the point where you like
you go through and you wonder if they're
gonna be there if they don't have a
presence that's gonna be everybody's
question but as you said before is like
how can you how can you take a long step
away and then kind of still be relevant
say if you say if you do what I'm
thinking like take that smaller and
you'll pass and come back with d3 in the
big way and have you been forgotten or
is the the point where maybe or the
other ideas are you looking for that
spacing from that original d2 d3 you
know of Activision and like you know so
you want separation or do you want or
you worry about being forgotten and
there's debates on both sides I'm sure
absolutely absolutely so a lot to know
in the future but for now we'll just
follow along with the seasons as we go
but next we got this game called anthem
so anthem has been two demos kind of a
tale of two demos as well with the
patches they made and things like that
now consoles had a differen
thing but even my feel on PC was
noticeably different I know in the open
demo my brothers my nephews they had
their base ps4 not a pro I think he said
it sounded like it was gonna take off
and that's the base I mean that those
things definitely can do that but yeah I
was it was not optimized for sure and I
know that's something they've been
working on for both console and PC so
optimization aside for this final I mean
round 2 of the demo I know you got to
play the VIP how you feeling about
anthem as you got a couple weekends on
it alright so um it's just what you said
at the beginning of last where pockets
well it's like anthem is just it just
feels good right like you jump in and
again that verticality that world you
know Iron Man is simulator and then but
more importantly I it's more than that
it's it's the combination it's
variability based and um it's just that
common that teamwork combination now
that looks like she can't wait she sold
you know um it's just that like ok if
you're running you know interceptor
you're on the ground and you're running
you know Colossus and I'm storm and you
know you're doing those combos it's
really nice let you see where the game
starts to shine with the individuality
of the classes I'm not necessarily sold
on the gun plateau the gunplay is kind
of secondary but it's ok because it's
not it's it's own thing it's not trying
to be destiny right right it's the
abilities aspect so I love that I'm
dying to dig deeper you know strongholds
get more that going on some little
things that low concerns I have on the
enemies popping up not there yet like
the mobs now her a lot of stuff is gonna
be fixed come launched yeah you know
obviously the first one the VIP demo did
not go well you know there was a lot of
issues and um you know they definitely
you know resolve that big-time with the
public beta you know I'm saying so I'm
good with that
I guess you know my whole thing is you
know jumping in seeing how the narrative
is I'm
I didn't know how that goes because we
know Bioware can tell a great story
right you know I feel that the demos
unfortunately have not really focused on
that it's more about just getting in
kind of thing and you know I get what
they're doing it's a demo I get what
they're doing but I'm very curious to
see when I play the campaign in the main
game am i emotionally invested because
people could say what they want about
destiny or whatever but they you know
they've improved and they've you know
forsaken is shown like you know we can't
like we had the argument like it
improved to the point where we they were
telling us yo they got key we gotta go
get him you know say hey you know say
like we were invested emotionally with
the whole aldrin thing right same thing
dreaming city to Queen a whole bit so I
want to know if that world is going to
capture me you know I'm saying
shout to OHA he said he loves the art
and design of an American word about the
game play and that's my thing now Marvel
thinks I know your anthem more than me
not that I'm not anthem I'm just if we
had to rank you putting a gun to my head
Division two is a little higher for me
and then you can't retire for you Oh for
me where they way to surpass division
for me is one lore that Louis got I got
a care I got to know what I'm doing why
I'm doing it
you know that kind of thing um you know
the progression and then the gameplay
the end the end game the gameplay look
we know strongholds you know that's
coming we have on the screen you know
this uh
calendar I'll let you get into that in a
few minutes and um you know I didn't
talk about Cataclysm we're gonna get
into that I want to know about that I
guess my only concerns E is to me their
gameplay loop mirrors Diablo or they're
not wrong and for me this is just my
personal preference I'm not the biggest
Diablo guy like when I play Diablo it
was boom I was in I was out he said I'm
saying like I wasn't I wasn't gonna do
this on super Hellfire difficulty it's
just that's just not me and the last
little complaint before I give it to you
is that they got to stop with these
loading screens for everything man Oh
lowenstein fit it Louis Louis before
that and you know the loot drop
it's just like um
how can I say like I'm used to you know
looking at your menu knowing what's
going on like everything seems to be
okay you can only do it in Ford Taurus
or the Forge so again it's it's
different
I got us just see when the full product
releases you know how invested does it
make me that I'm gonna keep doing this
for extended period of the game I know
I'm excited I'm gonna play it with you
we are rockin on PC it's going down I
just want to know how long and what else
they continue to do so that's what I got
now you you sell me eat tell me let me
tell you you talk to me so from the demo
both of them evenly at least for PC and
again I know console had some struggles
just with like optimization but believe
me is like even for me that's something
where my computer I can play stream and
record on the same damn computer at
1440p ultra so it's like I got a
powerful rig but when you go to anthem
the optimization I had to turn it down
to like kind of high medium it still
looked good but I should be able to do
all three of those things with what I've
got and that's one thing I want the full
game for mm-hmm so optimization I know
wasn't there now from weekend 1 to
weekend two he crashes the reloading
screen stuff like that
for at least my experience and again a
year miles may vary so that caveat is in
there good point mine was basically
solid for weekend - yeah like not hardly
any crashes no server reloading no 95
percent loading screens right now the
weekend I mean that's something coming
from the world of destiny six-month pad
like Jake's here or you've got this you
know patch or the black armory key that
it takes the entire season of what it's
about to get fixed and it's like you
know something like that in a week
that was impressive so and mine has been
also I feel hmm my not my relationship
but what I've watched the effort that
the producers and the people involved in
this game have put into the social
interaction and renewed feedback brave
me and this is something anybody can try
and do right before a quick
go yeah man bro I'm so glad you said
that because we all know ei yeah yeah
whoo yeah I get it
but let's not sell Bioware short here
this is probably the most what is it
mark Dora my Campbell am I getting the
names right my gamble and Ben Irving all
three of those yeah all three toes they
have been the most transparent dev I
have ever seen pre-launch like they're
doing QAS whatever you want to know
we're telling you and I'm glad you
mentioned I'm giving back to you I'm
glad you mention that because I know
this game gets killed with EA stuff and
I get that but um yeah man these guys
are really killing it with the
transparent they are not running from
anything like they are they're you know
even down to the whole quote-unquote you
know microtransaction whatever you know
controversy and they like look that
hasn't been determined yet this is
what's going on and I'm saying I get it
but I'm gonna give it back to you man
continue continue your your points on
our anthem oh no you're good I mean it's
it's one of those things I even I've
just watched and I followed it was Ben
Irving the one I've seen a lot I've
never seen somebody answer as many
Twitter questions if you go look at his
tweets in his replies
it is just insanity how much stuff use
replied to and this is pretty sure the
game like mm-hmm
it may be his job scuse me but oh my
like I've never seen that much
continuous thing I mean Cosmo and I read
it and stuff like that I mean they're
active in there but at least it like in
one place that I've seen and I'm sure
their speed like Community Managers in
other places but just on Twitter if you
followed him he was in my feet like
non-stop I was like dude do you sleep so
I made a shout-out to him I even just
sent him a tweet and he even replied
back to me it was just like hey you've
I've never seen somebody who I was like
just hats off thank you for the
communication it's been amazing and I
just said thank you and he was just like
awesome you're welcome like and and even
just like the chance to reply to that so
I was like hey cool I was like at some
point I want to drive down to Austin
just shake their dude's hand because the
seems like a really good guy absolutely
so that piece of this interaction has
got me I don't wanna say bias but to a
point where if there are little things
in there commuting sake communicating
saying hey we know this is in the full
game we know this is there
the way it's gone so far I have I have
more faith in some might because I've
seen the quicker changes I've seen what
they're trying to say I've watched them
talk about certain things as they go
through so if they say something I'm
actually thinking it's gonna be there at
least to me and I can be like hey it's
ei you're stupid this is ei don't think
that you know but in my eyes from what
I've watched so far at least Bioware and
the guys there have their hearts in this
thing and they think it's in the right
place I Greek shout out to those guys
absolutely I mean that's what you want
from your dev that's what you want from
your community manager that's what you
want from the marketing like you want
that level of transparency that is
unheard of and that's what's giving me
hope and let's be honest we want them to
succeed I mean these are the creators of
Mass Effect Dragon Age this is the 18
Bioware now granted some people what you
know if they're looking for this
single-player kind of experience this is
not this this is made to play with
friends but let's give them a chance
before we throw stones and uh you know
say that has you know a lot of people I
feel it's a very as gamers it's a very
overreaction Airy culture name you need
to rein it in like at the end of the day
we even call it a beta a demo whatever
it is it is a vertical slice of game
let's give it a chance let's wait to
release they've already showed
improvement from the was it the VIP to
the public now we waiting on release
they're telling about the change they're
being forthcoming you know we want to
get into the the acting beast is a
gameplay narrative thing and yep just go
for uh no I mean I just want to get into
a little more over here problems too hmm
so it it the loot is gonna feel like
Diablo the gunplay is not gonna feel
like destiny but there are certain
things about this game that I do have to
appreciate and there's certain things I
wish were in other places when you I
mean you're gonna be able to crank up
the difficulty in like Diablo sure but
also if I go into the normal activity as
a god at gear level for for a first time
in a long time in a Loutre shooter space
I get to feel that way yes
and in destiny your gear doesn't
honestly mean much of squat your stats
don't really matter that much you don't
get more
you don't have you can't go tear up a
normal activity and feel Opie you don't
get that opportunity and division
honestly would be about the same way too
because your gear matters but the
difference in anthem you're gonna have
your guns that drop randomly same things
division they're gonna have different
stats different things like that what
those aren't going to be as much focused
even the guns in Division probably have
more of an important play than the guns
in anthem because they're all ability
based yes but I mean say you go through
in Division and you get the little mini
turret machine gun it's not gonna have a
whole lot of perks and changes and
things to it or it's just you're gonna
unlock your perk and it's there it's
with you it's just a function destiny
you've got a similar thing you unlock a
fireball you unlock a grenade and they
are just what you they are the ability
you use and it doesn't really change the
difference for me with anthem which
actually kind of has me intrigued is the
abilities you get to use and which is a
lot of where the focus is going to be
are also part of the loot drops which
for one is gonna change how you play
because you might be leveling up you
have an epic you know epic level
character which for this one is say
legendary ish and I've got a combination
of abilities and it works really well
and then say I go through I do this one
harder dungeon and I go and I pick up a
master work ability and this is like say
I'm running a frost grenade and then I'm
using like fire to explode stuff for my
combo and then now I pick up a new
grenade now this is a fire primer but
this is like my new master work with
like four more perks and it has a tweak
on the abilities like if it sets them on
fire and they die or they explode or who
knows my abilities change with my gear
pickups so more of your character and
more of what you do are actually going
to continue to change and evolve and
improve with the abilities you pick up
so that's one of those things that takes
the evolution to a different place that
you're actually going to have the feel
and the other piece for me is the
classes this is one where both division
and destiny do not hold a candle at how
the characters feel different the
Colossus the Interceptor the storm will
ranger X they are they don't they are
not like each other I mean a Titan the
warlock on 100 yeah
they feel that jumps different in the
Super's but again I'm still having
roughly 200 health my mobility is still
linked to that one to ten stat and
everything is still fairly close I mean
yeah a warlock and a hunter feel
different but in turn it's mostly my
guns that I can move between characters
and I can generally do the same
activities mm-hmm when I go play a
Colossus and then I go play an
interceptor you can't have two different
classes play farther apart than those
two absolutely how many classes did you
play with played with everything except
I really I touched everything but I just
didn't deep dive Colossus play okay via
the other three I deep dived nice what
was your
I mean storm - interceptor then would be
a huge comparison as well had you I mean
Oh talk about those two for a second
because I want to know like what was
your enjoyment kind of ups and downs of
those two because those are pretty damn
far apart absolutely when I first got
into just trying to figure out what I'm
gonna mean I was leaning towards storm
just because let's be honest I'm a
warlock in destiny so he had that
warlock look so I'm like yeah that's why
I'm rolling so when I first touched
storm I didn't I was playing like
destiny I was like using my guns too
much and not utilizing the ability nor
utilizing the fact that he's supposed to
be in the air he gets to damage
resistance thing it I was just playing
with him wrong so initially it didn't
feel good right so I'm like you know
this is the first demo my money unlocked
everything at the end of the VIP that
was a first choice so then I sorry I got
a limited time we shot another class I
really went to intercept touch
interceptor I was like yo this is
different like this is this is speed
personified this is like warframe ninja
like you don't mean like I'm feeling
agile to dodging that you know the
jumping in the air the abilities disturb
the ninja star thing like it was quick
precision mailing I didn't think I would
like it like that like I really got into
innocent down like damn I might have a
dilemma yeah I was gonna mean store but
there like it intercepted now where the
second one came back the second demo and
then I went I said you know let me give
storm us another shot and
lay the way that's intended and fall I'm
not gonna talk about Ranger too much
because obviously fleeing to me touch
the most and I love Rangers -
jack-of-all-trades range is just great I
love the super ability of Ranger I think
that you get to get your Iron Man Tony
Stark missile back your said you lace
everything up that was lit now when I
touch storm the second time I started
using the primers and the combos and
lightning and then and you bring down
like you feel like Aurora from
what's-her-name forms from x-men you you
feel I see why they named it snowstorm
like this is literally the x-men
character you know I'm saying as a in my
Finn warlock form as far as I'm
concerned or self Elliott I see you in a
boy and all that don't you dare do that
but all jokes aside you know best meet
you bro
but um like seriously like it is so like
cataclysmic and then you really working
with your teammates and it's just I'm
just floating around feeling godly I was
like oh this is nice this is really nice
and he just just cool like even he
doesn't even run he glides across the
layer so glorious as a storm well just
like this is nice you know say so right
there I wanna touch callosity I didn't
feel I gave Colossus a fair shake
Michelle - your bro stone because I do
want to tank - I I do click a lot of
games where I tank character you take
characters so I seen the potential and
him with that shield and just be in that
front line and getting in there getting
in the mix you know I'm saying I'm dying
to really give Colossus another shot but
yeah you said it before we started this
topic which is that key would ant them
is everything is so damn distinct and
that's what they got going from you know
I'm saying and that game I'm dying to
see more more strongholds I'm dying to
see you know what they have going going
for but yeah that's my assessment right
now of the of the character bases nice
and honestly you nailed it so
and that's one thing it truly I would
love to have in the games as the feeling
of a new set of tunes - like you're
gonna start having roles because with a
storm you are not meant to be in the
middle of the act you're not two men on
the ground like smack at a guy in the
face
that's the Interceptor they are meant to
be in their mailing like you can freeze
the guy from far away and then the
interceptors gonna go rip rip into
shreds but you have two different
complete roles in that so that's why I
was like for my brother he was playing
it's like hey what do you want to run
well I'm gonna run uh you know I'm the
Interceptor so my mail in itself is a
detonator and I can have that aura and
run around so it's like hey if you can
run double primers he and I at least
know can pair off of each other and jump
in and work together do those combos and
actually and even if you match make with
two other people he and I know we can be
like hey we're gonna focus on this side
take care of these two you set them up
I'll knock him down and just work
together is this really cool pair
because we have completely different
personalities it's not like hey both of
us win destiny point our guns this
direction and shoot these guys yes so
it's it's a very very different feel and
I think that's kind of a nice piece for
me that's had my appeal now the other
pieces like the long-term and the
progression now you get to a point as
you're saying all right how many times
do I want to do some of this stuff over
and over all of these games we talked
about they are repetition there's no
doubt about it they all have the rectum
you I'm counting on that this is this is
being a card box we've had this I was
like hold on and it's like but it's also
what is your preference of your
repetition do you like Diablo just
melting stuff and feeling like your
characters more powerful are there more
raids in there we're just trying to get
different guns and that's your piece of
attachment is it division where you're
like I'm in the tactical cover and I
want to talk with my squad mates and set
up my Tom Clancy like raid on this
little squad and stuff and but in
general for most of these to get higher
gear to get that elusive stuff to keep
going there's a point where you're gonna
have to repeat content someplace or
another some way shape fashion or form
now
we watched division go through a really
good evolution from where it started to
where it ended yeah and that has come a
long long way and they've got years
under their belt to launch division 2
hopefully not the way destiny did
destiny to like as you say he's you guys
always say through it all that within
the in the bushes they through their
knowledge from you're like the first all
of three years in the bushes and we're
like hey let's try some new stuff you
guys like tell the gameplay was there
but thought so much they broke the feel
of the love of that game and forsaken
fight like they took year to like you
know unstuck their toe correct division
took content and added and evolved in
the underground and then you had
survival a whole new mode they added
like that evolution was impressive and
Ubisoft support of games like to like
Bioware devs their support has been
crazy but uber soft support of all their
games our Ubisoft everyone said they
have supported all of their recent games
Ghost Recon for honor division to like
almost an unprecedented 11 level that
the bio guys may have talked right now
and we got to see what they do but
division has just put put their time and
effort and they actually have actions
behind what they said and they've put a
game out there that it's done a lot and
that's where anthem has a big question
mark yes this is like the first year but
this is where you also can't hold three
years or five years of destiny against a
brand-new game and that's where it's
kind of got a tough spot to fill
absolutely I'll finish this written and
I'll let you go sorry for anthem it is
it's it is it is in its infancy yes and
holding it in comparison to how many
strikes are in destiny right there
you've got 14 from the you know first
year of destiny 2 and strikes and
releases and another expansion division
has a different whole different side of
like a lot more missions and things like
that and you're gonna have your critical
path but your in-game depth and breadth
is gonna be smaller to start now they've
got an act here and we'll talk about
that in a second but in my mind like the
repetition is gonna be smaller on anthem
at first and it's just going to take
them sometime because they are the
brand-new baby in the bunch so the
repetition is gonna be one if you like
the feel of it and you can stick with it
and if they support it well I think it
has high potential but it's definitely
going against some really heavy hitters
and that's I think where it's tough so
now you can go into my repetition
argument but that was a whole
long-winded answer stuff oh you know
that I mean it's it's you nailed every
aspect of it it's really not much I can
add to that I mean it's one of those
things where we know what our concerns
are you know say as far as the end game
as far as the repetition aspect the only
counter I would say would just be that
the difference with a destiny and a
division is there's a variety of
different endgame activities and what my
concern with our anthem is again not
saying they don't have it we're hearing
about Cataclysm I just want to know we
wouldn't have to find out what that
actually entails right you know
stronghold we know they have three we
got to see what each entail you know
saying we have to see the key is gonna
be you know shout to know vet and in the
chat you know he's made the key is gonna
be the support the consistent support
and is it really fair that I'm going in
on the end game so hard like you said
because it's you know it's an embassy
like that's these have all these years
to correct and fix and do all these
things to get themselves to a point to
where they had division had all this
time to recourse and I'm saying to get
themselves back to where they needed to
be you know kind of thing the key for
anthem to me is how adaptive that live
team is gonna be to me that's what it's
gonna be because at the end of the day
if they don't stay current if they don't
continue to content drop and we've seen
this with destiny one when they had
those droughts huh you know you remember
those comments are brutal and I remember
when Division one came on the scene
people forget that was a movement that
took Destiny's playerbase big time and
if they're not adaptive if they if
they're not able to adjust to the needs
of their community which I will say this
I will I do feel they are in the sense
that I love the feedback and the
apparently the team the key is how
quickly right how quickly can you adjust
and put these things in the game your
community once so that's gonna be the
key that's literally gonna be I think
like I said you nail pretty much all the
other points and that's all I got to say
but at the end of the days this is
exciting you know saying when February
comes out I'm right there with you man
like you know what's that date again
February 20 what is it 22nd 22nd I'm
right there with you day one loading up
we are going to hit it and I can't wait
man I can't wait to see how this thing
it's a fun year it's a fun year for
little shooters like Manus I love doing
this podcast with you because it's like
we are now like we're at the buffet
table right now
yeah and I'm stuffed and I'm still
looking at like two more plates bowls of
food that I'm trying it's it's it's
excessively too much but in a great way
like it's a it's a first-world wonderful
problem to have exactly get to take your
pick absolutely yeah so I mean anthem
does have a calendar it's getting
started quick we have the launch from
the 22nd and then they say in March next
month so they're definitely not wasting
much time echoes of reality is their
first act so they don't have dates on
the future acts but they do have two
future pieces planned as well I don't
know the dates the timing of all this
stuff but I mean they're trying to hit
the ground running yeah and it is
February 15th so it is literally next
Friday if you have origin premiere
access or EAX as you get your 10 hours
yes so it is the week early with the e
axis and that is one piece I'm just
gonna throw it out there
the e1 sister convoluted as hell oh I
know that sucks and everybody's like
when you'll release a chart to explain
how your game is released what the
hell's wrong and that's a print what
it's that's a point where it's EA and
access and that's not apply where are
the EAS piece of it and there's nothing
they can do it just feels rough when
they have a chart I've got three updates
they've got the evolving world so you're
gonna have the world actually working on
changing and that's kind of thing if you
in the demo when you saw them launch the
storm or the shaper storm or whatever it
was the weather effects you
and I yeah mean strike in the ground by
the way that lightning animation so good
like one of the cooler animations by so
good
they've got update to stronger together
don't even know what that is that is
update three the Cataclysm and that's
one of those bigger larger events that
they've got but everything below they've
got new events quality of life new
rewards expanded progression system I
mean that alone if you're looking on
progression trying to add something else
in there that's good a new stronghold
cuz it's launching with three so if it's
four already we're getting there pretty
quick guilds leaderboards new missions
in the Cataclysm all that's in like
March yes so they have now how long how
quickly this stuff comes because
obviously you have a launch the nice
thing is again like division as well for
both of these they plan outside of like
you know cosmetics or maybe if they ever
really said a new javelin that might be
like hey here's ten bucks to like that
would be kind of insane and those are
the ones that they might actually charge
for cosmetics will be free or at least
Erna Belen game you do not have to
purchase you will be able to earn
everything just depends on your play
time um but also the future releases of
content for now unless they go like
anthem to or crazy thing that's all free
so I mean that and division both have
that over destiny it's like that future
stuff it's not an annual pass it is all
of this stuff that you get because you
bought the game and you just keep
playing it so even if you buy division
or if you buy division you by destiny
you buy anthem nice thing about the
other two the new ones anthem and
division well if you step away from one
and this new thing comes back well you
don't have to pay for it just turn them
turn the game back on so the first month
looks kinda cool I the Cataclysm is a
big thing that they've been announcing
but I mean a new stronghold the expanded
progression system little tidbits and
there are things that I want to see
where they start taking this stuff how
the game evolves and how quickly they
have all did but all in all I was like
I'm excited for all of the stuff that
we've got but I was like if if they can
live up to what they've got and they
continue to like evolve the game and
keep new stuff going I think the grind
will be something I can maybe it's a
weekend I do
anthem one with my brother and then it's
another one where I do division with
some other friends or whatever it's like
and I see both being a thing played I'm
looking forward to all of this stuff so
speaking of this other game that we've
been talking about a lot to it this is
your baby right here so we got my
division to beta is live as of what
literally yesterday actually yes sir so
I'm not gonna say much because I feel
like I threw a mouthful out there
division 2 beta Cognito take take it
away man I won't talk about it you know
here's the thing I mean as you know
Division I have a very controversial
history with as a destiny fan I must
admit the fan bowing at the time and I
was hostile towards this game you know
who's this game new on the scene coming
for my beloved destiny how dare they you
know I wasn't a fan way back back in
Division one days and I cuz I was
destiny hardcore you know I wasn't
really ready to see another Luther
shooter and then obviously you know you
know full disclosure I'm from New York
City that's when I'm on arrays so when I
saw the one-to-one ratio and for hours I
wall that's New York that's Madison
Square go
these trees like this is the game right
so um you know as I got into it and I'm
like no this is not that bad you know
it's really cool more tactical more
along like like alongside of a rainbow 6
/ meets Ghost Recon kind of a deal you
know and I played it all the way up to
the campaign and I liked it but I got
bored pretty quick and the thing what
did it for me was you know lack of
in-game he had these things called
incursions wasn't really a fan I felt
like glorify strikes and um you know it
was just you know enemies were very
bullet spongy and me you've talked about
this in the past he where it's you know
bullet spongy works in destiny with
space magic and monsters bullet spongy
with a guy in a hoodie you know running
at you with a bat and you shooting him
35 time he ain't dying Tana took me out
of the element right so that was my d1x
division
one experience I cooled on a game very
fast I was like okay I did what I had to
do but this is not taking any more time
from destiny and then as I predicted
that's how it was a civil war with my
friendless right oh it was it was we get
in an argument shot of the katsu ja the
King David like it was really like my
friends cheated on destiny and they went
nay like we're at division now and I'm
like that games gonna fail no it's not
it's gonna do this I'm like do it it's
gonna fail I'm telling you and lo and
behold they have to admit it they hate
when I rub it in it faded and it faded
what a combination of thinking freedom
because it was hacks even a lot of
things but more importantly it also
faded because of the end game now let's
fast forward to Division two
surprisingly as you've been hearing me
or every last word podcast we do I've
been excited and more excited the more I
hear about it out here about ending all
the things that I had a problem with
Division one you don't I mean it seems
to be kind of addressing with division
two and the other thing is I felt it had
a full feature list you know dark zone
which a cool concept it necessarily
field was implemented great and the
first one now they're doing these
occupied ones they're doing you know
this whole bit that I like you know that
they have balanced across the board but
let's get into this beta turned it on
plan on the x 4k HDR looks outstanding
the game looks really good now is it
anthem looking no I'm not gonna go there
but it really looks good and the first
thing you notice off the back is the
wide streets that the field of view that
the draw distance oh it's a minute feels
like a living populated world and what I
really like about it is they really dumb
double down on the simulation aspects
like before in the old division you kind
of run around and heal at the same time
oh no no no no you cannot do that now
you know say you have to stop what
you're doing physically stop all other
actions to heal yourself and inject
yourself you know just the little things
the noise is the enemy AI they
flanked you they have different factions
they regress him some will Flay back you
can't stand to cover the same place
they'll throw grenades they'll do
different tactics to get you out of just
staying in one spot but the main
important thing was the time to kill
once they lowered it it feels real now I
was like if I shoot a guy like four
times he's dead
like that's how it's a post if it's more
of a realistic real-life take on it and
then you know it really it really
started to shine and they have the mid
maxing the gear drops and you know the
first thing where made me smile young a
lot of you I got me some kneepads and I
got me some other very like a vest a new
part of a set the set gave me bonuses
and I'm like like this is what I'm
talking like I would be so easy for the
no one comment like the mint like one
thing about division that is completely
different from anthem Division wants you
to be in their menus want you to stop
what you're doing and compare one you
know backpack of one gun to another one
and really break it down on your
playstyle and how it you know how it
works with your skills that you pick on
shout out to the skills you know they
got different new skills now turret this
that you know again if you like tactical
if you like squad based teaming up with
your friends you know and the lasting
story wise they selling meee it
literally feels like Washington DC has
been taken over and you've got to
liberate this thing
slowly one at a time then they got the
settlements aspects where you got
communities where you know if you do
work for them and you appease their
leaders they'll help you and then like
if you're in a zone where you by
yourself you show up a flare and the AI
comes up do like it feels like a living
world and I'm in I am in I've been the
biggest it's funny because the division
guys that I'll cool with they were on
the fence coming into the visit to yeah
I don't know what me I'm like they're
appealing to every proud
I have with the first game is it perfect
no there's still some issues you know
I'm saying with certain little things
and bugs in the bay that I've
encountered but in my mind there's no
doubt that those things would get you
know fixed and as far as the last point
I'm making I'm talking a lot the last
one I'll make is um you haven't probably
touched what I talking about anthem so
you're fine excited um first of all the
mission structure is dope verticality
exciting type of missions infiltration
things I saw one mission when it was um
they were like a our name and a faction
it's called a propaganda mission they
set up like a what you go like a truck
and they had like a megaphone and it's
you know spread apart and it's funny it
is like yeah like you have to shut that
down and it's just funny but the whole
thing is the bullet sponge aspect now
when you do face a human boss that is
kind of like the sponge is now he comes
out in all this armor like these big
armored suits so now it's like when I'm
shooting this guy 32 I'm like okay I
understand because look at he's got this
big you know meaning you know I'm saying
like it's really I look I played a lot
of the main um it's really well done I'm
very excited I think I think they got
one man I think if you know said if they
do what they got to do and you know the
very final point is I looked in that
Start menu one week shot to my boy
Eric's gaming as he interviewed the devs
they got raids man eight player rates
that and and not not only is that they
mentioned in mechanics they were very
specific
Eric's has a good video out right now we
talks to the dead and he kind of
questions them on raids and he not only
did they say there's a raid like maybe a
one week after release
he said raids plural so they're coming
with the content and you got pvp you got
dog so there's a lot of things to do man
so this were I'm leaning excited you
don't see how it goes you know come
launch you know it's not until March so
I still have time to get blazed my
anthem
see what's going on but all in all you
know I think it's one of those things
that if you like Division one and you
had issues I think I'd be happy for
people who really didn't like the vision
I don't know if they sways them you know
I'm saying they may say more the same
Division one point five I get it but I
feel it I feel for a beta for their
first impression I thought it was strong
so I'm done rambling it is now you I am
dying to know your opinions of this beta
uh so I think some of the things you
said nailed a couple subtle things that
give it more life than it ever had
before and I think that some of the
things they learn from d1 shooting I
like when you do a control point you
shoot up the flare and you have some AI
come in and they help mm-hmm they're not
just useless like you know character
shells that don't do a damn thing like
that gave a different feel when you like
you shoot up a flare I'm going along and
then they come over they help and they
get there like five minutes later I've
got this attack going on I was playing
yesterday stream it a little bit I felt
like I was kind of like gotta stay in
cover can't get work too much gotta walk
that the guys flanking to the sides I'm
like underground in a parking garage and
all of a sudden there's like two sides
this time looking down all the sudden
get a shot from the left because the guy
went down the far side I didn't see him
come up it has a really cool tactical
feel and that's exactly what it's meant
to be I mean this is Rainbow six the
living world yes unfortunately the whole
world got screwed up right it's not like
hey these guys took over this building
and I gotta go invade as the SWAT team
know you live in a world that is now
that building and the whole world got
messed up and you got to try and survive
every street corner every building you
enter every fight you encounter some
guys might come in behind you it's it's
definitely head on a swivel constantly
and I think too as you said the like
even New York wasn't technically one to
one they had some things that were
spot-on like it was really good but they
couldn't with New York's massive and I
couldn't obviously do it all they said
what DC they truly did one to one like
this area is damaged
here it and having never been there as
like kind of be cool to ever go there
but like yeah on the White House lawn
first part yeah that felt good that felt
really cool like walking into the Oval
Office when I explored I was like hey
here we go there you go
and this is a gun where I desperately
know I need a scope yes okay gotta have
my scopes cuz right now like iron sight
and everything I feel like trash and I
also want to start getting either some
mods or some stocks and things like that
so I can get some of these guns more
stale stable because they get like a
mule okay and this is kind of a thing
where I do want to kind of go a
difference of words go for it so their
world building in this game is amazing
all their lore and like story cutscenes
and stuff like that is kind of how an
action movie may so that's what I was
like the lore and story not so much but
the world they build in these things you
are in it you are neck-deep and it feels
really good like the world building is
amazing when you have some of those
little cutscenes be like hey there's
this little like the characters I don't
care about they just send me on my next
mission okay so far so I mean those
don't have as much as a touch the one
mission with Mathias getting a feel for
him having him split in Anthem I feel
even a little more attached to him than
just what I saw so far okay so there's
the difference in attachment entities so
what being you the opposite on
connection low weight with anthem and
division as far as lore characters it's
funny you said that cuz I'm actually
like I walked in and there's a lady she
looks like her shoulder got one to hell
I would did I like no and it's like and
okay it was like she went through hell
obviously we're getting we go and save
her daughter and then you bring her back
and she's like I want to get back out
there she's having trouble running this
whole stronghold and stuff and then but
it's just like the the other NPCs and
things like that is gonna be like
they're just so they don't feel the
like and that's like the voice-acting
the feel of it is just kind of it didn't
have didn't have the other piece to it
like the other I don't know I haven't
played enough and maybe you'll spend
some more time with these characters but
as it's like you unlock an area than you
like you know you can contribute to that
stronghold but it doesn't feel like I'm
gonna have that in-depth attachment I
mean I never did in Division one
I played basically 1 through 30 like I
had the had the technical dude I had the
safety dude and I had the medics lady
and I had those three people I talked to
but it was more like I didn't feel like
I got as much out of those personally
your defense did the the main issue I
think the reason why anthem will have
the advantage on that is because the
main protagonist actually talks in the
back to silent protagonist so that you
really can't get that emotional
connection maybe as much as you would
like because he's just a you know he's
the the mutant he's the strong mute
turns around and just helps people kind
of stuff but I will say this in and
divisions defense I was it with anthem
this is where I thought I would be more
connected to the campus yeah I know you
sent Matthias
is that who's the one that you give the
thing to and the name and he's got his
personalities like the way they handled
him and actually breaking him into three
and like all that craziness like spoiler
sorry demo
yeah with it I'm not doing I'm like more
like I mean even though we split him he
had three different personalities and I
actually got a feeling of I could see
like okay this is this guy's this side
this side this side and I feel like so
far like and I gotta play more and talk
to some of these people but before it's
just like oh I'm angry I'm like I'm this
person in a you know dystopian
Washington DC and I'm just this military
person who's yeah I'm just I'm pissed
off and you don't go to opens up and
it's like there's a like I know it's
like a crappy situation for them to be
in but I didn't have like it's like you
know every all of those situations like
what military-type person who's trying
to run a stronghold and they're just mad
and angry and not that fun and it's just
and that's the personality that fits
that role because to be a leader in that
situation you can't have a whole you you
are no BS and you're just straight to it
but in turn for me to sit there and
listen to it I was like all right
it's interesting how both games affected
us different laws where me I'm like yo
this world really feels run over you
know I said the world-building
amazing right the way you look around
the way it feels like the stuff in the
streets the parked cars
but then when I go talk to a character
you I'm just like uh it well that one of
them it was outdoors too is in the plate
that middle stronghold whatever like
whatever they're called in trouble and
throwing thing it was just one of those
points where like it's like third-person
the whole time but I'm talking this guy
hey this is the crafting dude but I'm
like he's a blind dude like looking off
to my left from the table and I'm
standing right in front of him and I'm
like I know that's probably a little
thing but I was like that just ripped me
out of the world doesn't matter dude Oh
see what B is like lizard the chick you
know she can't answer she can't to me
I'm like like I don't feel like why I'm
doing this like I don't feel yet it it
through like yo like why I hear like
none that no one really grabbed me yet
and again it's a vertical slice you know
saying we gotta see you know we we I
will say that I'm more confident that as
I play it I will have that connection
but as of right now you're definitely
higher than me with their characters
than I because you know what here's the
thing I'm such a
what's up fuzzy Belvedere in the
building I see you bro what's up monkey
punch good to see bro oh and Joseph
Elliott peace man thanks for coming
through you know what it is I'm spoiled
by Bioware like I am a Dragon Age Mass
Effect guy like the minute I play the
vintage Bioware games I'm in emotional
with the characters from the very start
and for some weird reason just not yet
with anthem but it could be just where
they started and it's just they put me
in the middle of the game you know I'm
saying like I need to see my cinematics
like I need to see that Bioware feel and
I haven't
felt it yet as a hardcore guy like are
you a Mass Effect guy would you like did
you pay it with dragons age and all that
stuff I was like suddenly that is a
gaping hole in my world of gaming so see
for you you looking at this like oh this
is solid for me the bar is so high from
them like with Commander Shepard a name
any bot like major but like they tell
character stories so well that the
minute you press play and you start the
disk you're in and anthem for whatever
II didn't give me that yet but I'm
willing to give him a shot because again
that was just the demo middle of the
game can you feel I just want to see you
know the whole thing the story the
intended protagonist the antagonist and
really get into it so that's all I got I
mom let you finish up you're good
I mean that's one of those things - it's
like it's a living world live service
game Mass Effect as I start to finish
our PG story so they truly can like
we're gonna build this story all these
interactions are gonna be there the
focus more on anthem is may not be as
strong in that one so people coming from
like I love the Bioware's at the hell of
a bar to hit yeah you're right and to be
a living game yeah it's not gonna be an
easy thing for them to do both and
destiny went through four years of like
do I really care about the story okay
forsaken finally grabbed me how long did
that take like I don't think bye or is
gonna take that long but if it doesn't
come out of the gates running there
trying to get a lot of things happening
and it's not just a you know a package
with a bow on it that you unwrap in Mass
Effect and play yes there is a
difference in that and division I will
say there are certain things it does
very well for the story that I always
thought almost put me more in the middle
of the mix than almost anything else
I've ever had in a game four story is
those living moments where you kind of
have that projected scene yes what are
they called because I'm blinkin knew it
would be both yes yes the way some of
the story was done like you can't be
there but how do you tell a backstory
but you don't do a cutscene well if I'm
in the world and I'm walking through
rooms and I see this projection of like
hey here's a voiceover line this person
who's sitting here and they're like
story
boards but they're 3d um they're it's
really well like I like that feel and
that was a cool thing I thought I was
like man if any other games use this
just occasionally throw it in there
would be just in the world feeling like
in I'm actually standing at this space
where this happened and there was even
one were just like looking for a girl
who she was in an apartment like some
guys came in there was a tussle then you
see she like runs down the apartment
like fire escape ladder then she's in
the street and then she's like farther
in the corner building in it like pieces
those together really well and that's
the division piece where I was like
those are the ones that actually hit me
more than the didn't the basic
interactions with like yeah here's my
medic here's my medical ward lady and
I'm gonna just like saucer her and do
missions but it's like hey don't save
this guy over here like there were there
were different pieces of that game that
spoke to me and didn't okay fair enough
that's not that actually you explained
it very well but yeah it's like the guns
are they feel like no it's like it feels
that you said it already if you like
Division one this is the vision one like
polished max content added new world
summer time different seasons like
hopefully they're taking everything
they've learned and they've made
Division one better yes in so many like
the guns feel better the perk system
seems like somewhat not what is the word
I'm looking for not simplified but like
smoothed out like nuts or it's quite so
convoluted the perks and all these
things just seem to be a little more
flowy the your stats that you're working
towards aren't just these crazy like
300,000 health and 10,000 armor and like
yeah like those are not quite there
you're looking for I guess smaller
pieces which is good so I mean
everything I'm seeing about it I like so
far and that's why I was like I want to
play deep dive I got like seven crashes
in like the few hours I got to play so
it wasn't a big fan of that oh yeah but
they literally patched it last night
so I'm gonna jump in after I get her
video done and that's gonna be a decent
chunk of my day of playing that again so
well maybe have more to say but I like I
want to see how the dark zone feels I
want to kind of get a little bit more
and I'll try and pay more attention to
the characters too so we'll just have to
see but yeah my opinions on it are how
does cuz mine on division 1 level 1 to
30 was great like it always felt like I
had something to do these little side
missions I'm gonna go get this you know
shade tech I'm gonna save this whole you
know all these little pieces and side
missions were good then once I'm all I'm
like I'm done I mean how didn't had legs
it didn't capture me I'm with you that's
how I felt with division 1 it middle II
didn't in that's why I'm excited because
everything I've read in every developer
you know I was on the streams I've been
how you've been on it with anthem I've
been kind of on it you know say like you
know with it and they really seem to be
addressing everything that I want as far
as the end game but yeah I mean it's one
of those things I think tools in a chat
said it like if you didn't like Division
one I don't know if the vision 2 is
going to really sell it I think it's
more of people who love division 1 or
people who were like us that maybe
played it enjoy what we play up into 30
and then got out of there and I think
maybe they have a shot and trying to
hold us with this one so we'll see we'll
see it's it's it's a lot of competition
man it's a lot of things on the market
and it's gonna it's it's gonna be what
type of game appeals to you you know I'm
saying what do you want your Iron Man
similar do you want your cooperative
thing you want that diablo style grind
and loot drop or you know do you want
your tactical do you want your boots on
the ground and you know i'm saying you
want a mid max and you want to do all
this minutia it's you know which in
which your gear sets and all this other
stuff it's it's literally a preference
and to be honest you really can't go
wrong either right yeah it's it's big
the quality now with these games are
really good and it just comes down to
your playstyle and your preference and
you know what you want what you want to
dedicate your time to yeah I mean and
you you nailed it
there's there's a lot to play there's
even more if you want to step away for a
single-player game and then try and find
some spot time to be like hey I got a
four or socorro or Kingdom Hearts 3 and
you're like those are in 50 60 hour
games anyway and these games just start
at 50 or 60 hours like they're gonna be
living breathing worlds that are gonna
happen for a while both anthem and
division are gonna have free content
that keeps going if you can play them
both if but I mean if you if tactical
speaks you divisions gonna have an
ongoing world with raids and free
content and they've got like four years
under their belt anthem is gonna be a
work in progress but I feel like they've
got a decent start and we're just gonna
have to see where it goes
it's got my interest piqued and if you
like the Iron Man fantasy and the way it
feels I will say like the animations the
fluidity of those characters and like
the lightning strike down there's a
difference and destiny has it's like the
gunplay and that's the blows both of
them away it's first-person you're
attached to them I mean you're looking
down the sights of those guns I'm
attached to my go figure like it's my
second child because the would that gun
for me I know how it feels I know how it
shoots
I've got like the range them a little
bit of mods on it it's like in its mine
and I've used it so much in people's
last words they're not forgotten the
quests and things you go for for this
one thing that you use you live and die
by your weapons these other two are both
anthems 90 light is like 75% abilities
even more so the guns are an
afterthought for kind of continued
damage and things like that
you've got division which is more
focused on the guns and cover shooting
and the tactics and the guns are very
important to that but they're not gonna
have the same feel as destiny because it
is third-person I mean if they they
can't now some guns will definitely
start to feel better and the accuracy I
would say like the guns in Division two
are still gonna still be better than
anthem for sure and that stuff may get
better over time but you have different
focuses in each game different grinds
different build importances abilities
and random roles and stuff like that
versus your gear sets and things like
that versus destiny which is did I get
my new exotic and I can just go break
the game now I mean there's they all
have their different piece
I agree and I'll double down on what you
said claim both of these games and both
of them are great and we both had the
discussion about you know what appeals
to you is what you're gonna go with but
let's be real
destiny fans ain't nothin messing with
our play love you guys love the chin
here pushing punchy but I realize what
you know what I realize I had this
conversation with a Lord addict and even
with the vision we got to see I'm as
much as I'm saying Ray Ray Ray yeah you
know shoutout to I believe it was a
secret in your chat you know 8-player
raid could be messy you know we don't
know how that's gonna play out right we
don't know if it's really gonna have
mechanics and stuff like that and again
what I'm saying to say all this is that
Bungie set the bar so I feel sorry
sometimes that these guys gotta come
behind what buddy said because gameplay
you've got I mean that gunplay you've
got that feel you got a spaceman you got
the cooperative aspect and you've got
their raids in their endgame and I'm
saying and those are the bars you have
to aspire to you you have to look at
vault of glass and you don't say last
wish and you know taken King you know
say like that's a lot you gonna mean and
also we both seem a little have some
problems coming out the gate you know
you know with server issues or
what-have-you and stuff like that so I
know part of me Bungie even though a lot
of people worried about destiny I know
part of it was like yeah you say you're
gonna make a little shooter huh you're
gonna you're gonna jump in this world
where where the community will kill you
in a minute when you do something
romance so unforgiving right like
bungees been through that fire so
they're sitting back and trust me
they're taking notes they're seeing
what's going on in this crime it's it's
it's a triple threat match right now
it's like a wrestling it's triple threat
match we got to see you know say you
know we got to see what's gonna happen
but for sure from a core gameplay
standpoint as much as people gonna say
I'm fanboy I still think Destiny's gonna
be fine because there's still those
things that destiny does that is just
unreplicated boys just you you just
can't copy that you know saying certain
things you know saying so I think ball
for these other games
you know fill niches in their own
respective right and they distinct
enough that fans of those you know type
styles of games are gonna like it too
but this is a fun time I can't wait I
really can't wait to see how the rest of
this year plays out and who does what
who content drops on this day it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be fun I love the
stuff it's I'm with you I mean you said
all the stuff that's for him bouncing
around in my head too I mean how do you
have the mechanics of last wish or a
king's fall or a vault of glass as a
vault of glass as a first raid set the
bar high and then me we would throw this
raid fight before mm-hmm the way crota
felt for a hive raid fit that theme but
those raids are very very far apart
mm-hmm so you have vault of glass the
very you know methodical vex time all of
those pieces were in their hive is
absolutely fury fanatic crazy
animalistic almost just insanity you
have the Kings fall with like jumping
mechanics and a giant ogre and that's my
worry about division yeah yeah is how
does an endgame that's not a kill box
with an APC in it which that's what
turned me off so about the first time
how do you give it a lot of variety a
lot of mechanics when you are stuck in
reality mm-hmm and that's where anthem
has the freedom to be like we don't we
don't know what plate planets that it's
on will hopefully get some of that
stories we go the kind of state hush on
that but all the things that happens
with the shapers and things they can
have flexibility to just be like okay
giant curveball space monster I mean you
can't argue because everything's on the
table in reality in a world where you
have like the dollar flew and you have
Washington DC how again like how
creative can you get and that's again
what we have to see to the last plate
and I'm then I'll shut up cuz I've been
going on long Oh
what I noticed they did is they have a
third faction in this third faction that
once you get to endgame you know um
basically comes in and takes over the
map think of them like the takin
so to speak right and like the a and
apparently it's very military slash um
robotic they got like these robotic type
dogs being around right and I said oh
you're going into some I don't say
fantasy but they're going into something
that's not just strictly a human thing
all the time so I think that's one run I
don't know we got to see how they nail
it you know saying we got to see but um
I was impressed by it because I'm like
like you said like how are they going to
get us to just be invested when
everything is based on realistic you
know characters and stuff like that so I
think that's an interesting take and I
want to see again the key I want to see
how that rate is I'm dying to see you
know how that goes how they what do they
take from destiny what do they do
distinct you know I'm saying that eight
players like how the hell does it match
me like how what's going on it's a lot
of question it it's gonna be fun the
same thing when it would anthem what is
this Cataclysm what is going on with um
you know just in general with the
strongholds and more of these missions
you know these contracts you know we got
to see what that's gonna be a lot of
stuff a lot of questions on both sides
we got to see them
mm-hmm yeah I was like so sleep now yes
about the way I can say it because
you're not gonna sleep later shout out
to cram in chat by the way thank you for
the sub but seriously guys this is you
you get to pick your choice of candy
flavor now and there's a lot of options
on the table there's a lot of different
candy bars you got your Reese's your
sour patch kids you got your
butterfingers you got all your different
stuff out there and it's what it's what
appeases to you and that's the thing
you're just gonna have to see and
honestly for some people if you wait
about a month on both of these if you
wait till like April maybe May like if
you don't have to rush into anything
you're in your cool watching while you
play destiny for a little while to see
what's really gonna be the thing that
adds a lot to order might be the one for
you and another one it's
gonna take a little time for some of the
dust to settle from new releases the
first raids the cataclysms the you know
the contracts did you get an anthem
you've got the the invasion of the end
game of that other faction that
basically invades different places all
the time mm-hm
all of those things are gonna be the
evolution we'll have to see and probably
about two months in we're probably gonna
know a lot yes but like I think the
discussion we have around May is gonna
be very telling of the future of both of
these big time so two hours and 15
minutes later we made it hashtag long
point white returned yeah so flashpoint
long point the last word we definitely
have all the words before the last word
get in there yes sir there's been a lot
of fun this morning there's a lot to
look forward to I want to give me I just
want one quick concern for both anthem
in division your biggest concern for
both anthem stalled airs endgame worried
again just me personally I'm not a
Diablo in-game fan so I'm hoping there's
other things I'm hoping that you know
these cataclysms are something different
and you know cuz you put it this way but
to me they are in the best position to
do a rade could you imagine an anthem
raid howl it that would be like they've
got the verticality imagine two people
flying up to one section of a strut you
know I mean like it could be to me like
if they get around to doing something
like that it could blow away something
like destiny in my pit
like they've got a setup based on their
world and the way that game plays and
controls it could be something and I
want to see like huge you know
Oryx tile taking Kings now bosses right
absolutely fighting that like that add
them to me has so much because of when I
didn't hear radon miner but again I
don't want to disrespect because
strongholds could be dope right
strongholds could be straight scream
said it I feel like
it's witty man Raider was a sweaty man
would be in skin you imagine that bro
can you imagine these spate for I'm
pretty sure you'd crash everybody's game
I don't know if that world kidding I
don't know if the computers could handle
what I can imagine in my mind because
the effects the particles you'd have
like for storm supers drop it on the bus
blow up live in oh my god you'd break
you'd break systems computers would be
catching on fire Xboxes would be jumping
out windows like oh my god though I'm
just imagine like could you just imagine
fighting some big Oryx elbows and like
two people are in midair circling him
shooting two people on the ground you
don't say like it could be epic I want
to see and again I don't want to say
like it's not because I haven't seen
these strongholds I haven't they could
have all that you know I'm saying
so we'll see so that's my concern with
and then division is just like you said
you know um because it's so based in
realism right how are they going to
translate and and the other thing is
let's be real like one thing that
destiny has over both of them is exotics
right like that that in-game loot that
is distinct like how excited am i if I'm
gonna get another m16 with a gold yeah
it's gonna be an m16 with a name on it
like it but it's not gonna feel that
different exactly like that's the only
thing I worry long-term with that you
know that their progression with with
loot is a little different it's more
about the stats and how it affects your
abilities and all that stuff you know or
your damage numbers higher yeah you know
I'm saying like I I gotta see how all
that plays out is it truly fun and
rewarding you know to get that loop kind
of thing you know I'm saying so that's
all I got what about you what are your
concerns I'm very curious about this I
mean honestly for me it's gonna be how
the how the loot drops to keep it fresh
and to be able to give me a reason to
keep playing that high level
- Lara the things that I'm grinding for
these master works these legendary items
making a big enough difference just do I
want to go smash my head against harder
content just to try and level up to that
higher higher in a level or is it just
or is it smaller now some of the things
they've shown like master work either
weapons or master work gun are abilities
and the fact that your abilities like
can have a distinction to them that will
be different is kind of cool
if you get a burning orb that when you
set it on fire is also going to have
instead of just shooting somebody in the
face when you throw it it's also gonna
have a fire effect on the ground and
that's like the master work ability has
its own thing if there are more
distinctions to the higher level
abilities that set them apart to give
you a little bit more variety that will
be something I'm looking forward to but
as again same thing for you if I burn
through and I get to say work on Grand
Master one I work on that kind of
getting some cool stuff getting high up
there in level does Grand Master 2 & 3
or is the anything or is the living
piece gonna keep me involved because the
divisions barking right at its back
absolutely and then for division it's
gonna be for me how all the things that
I think I heard I liked even though I
fell off the game of division that they
brought forward I wish like survival was
in there from the start oh I love
survival because that was the level
playing field how does the dark zone
feel the dark zone probably pissed me
off more than anything it because it's a
point where if this is where the endgame
was and that's where I get my gear and I
run in and then I get shot by dumb
people who are just trolling everyone
and I can't if I can't progress mm-hmm
that's an issue absolutely so and then I
think somebody said it as well and yours
or yeah fuzzy Belvedere the solo
progression that's how I will Templi
play some games where that streams
whether it's other people I do a fair
amount of stuff solo and I have concerns
on both of these honestly yes or that is
Clara I think I think we got it got it
nailed out as far as uh on both sides so
we got see how this bad boy plays out me
yeah so to wrap it up well you guys know
I'll probably be streaming division beta
some it's a quiet week in the world that
doesn't need no shattered throne shout
out to everybody who was in my stream
foreshadowed throne this past weekend
that was kind of amazing
I had 80 people watching when I finished
wrapping that thing up and that about
blew my socks off so but it was I was in
the moment they're streaming that thing
it was I literally I had done it like
three weeks past had some practice first
time mm-hmm
like literally said Fred would I wish he
was there for like take one and I wish I
could have been like and it stayed at
one take so that was a hell of a lot of
fun but right now yeah guys just catch
me streaming been doing that quite a bit
more follow me on Twitter as well just
for updates of stuff like that but you
guys know where to find me Ichiban piss
everywhere and shout out to the subs and
chat shout out to all the support lately
past a thousand followers on Twitter
finally working on working on catching
up to you I got a long ways to go in the
Twitter world sir but I actually broke
that 1000 mark so that was kind of cool
and twitch has just been a ton of fun
lately and there's just a lot of stuff
to do I can't keep up you know you
working well yeah hey work and doing
good love you see the progression man
big things ahead for a bounce it's good
stuff man well yeah I mean for me you
know the deal you know Twitter at Lord
Cognito all that good stuff and yeah man
I know podcast will be back on Sunday
just the Lord's we got a lot to discuss
there will be some odd division and
anthem talk in this will stay tuned as
well not as deep as the last word you
know good to talk about some things and
in reference to the devil babies that
release Paul oh yeah man we're gonna
have to do some hot topics in gaming
we're gonna talk about everything
the infamous I should say infamous but
the amazing launch of apex legends that
will be discussed and we'll talk about
also the future of the titanfall
franchise or everybody wants to know
what's going on with that we've got some
great topics please tune in Sunday p.m.
Eastern on the iron Lords podcast
channel that is the realm of the Lord's
man so check us out it should be a fun
fun show and a shout out to both chat
today both chats outstand
man outstanding thank you Joe Matic you
know really appreciate the support you
know really really like to see you guys
in here and engaging Christopher Hart
you're late from anywhere we ended up
closing out Jesus but shot everybody to
it's fuzzy screen everybody was really
good today keeping us on our toes and
having a good time and this is again we
do this because we love it
you know last word we're gonna talk
about these looter shooters their
passion St always will be on love but we
got to talk about the competition and
it's good to see you guys still rock out
with us on that level because um in
gaming right now it is a fun time it is
a lot to play there's no excuse for
anyone to be bored right now yeah play
would you like that's the biggest thing
there's a I think people have said it
was like why are all these hate coming
up for games that aren't even out yet or
if it's not your thing
don't go bash it everything just go have
fun with what you enjoy easiest way to
say it absolutely all right well on that
bombshell stealing that one from top
gear but honestly it's been a great time
this morning see you guys next week
follow us both go listen to the iron
Lords podcast it's amazing every time
those guys seriously you guys are
cracking me up usually when I'm
listening I got to kind of maintain some
laughs and it's still a blast but also
just the the knowledge the thoughts the
deep dives you guys do some amazing
stuff so listen to them as well guys and
you'll be in a good place much
appreciated man thank you and thanks for
the support as well for the developer
that came out for Ash and dark Bradley
fantastic deep dive with him if you're a
fan of that game you want to learn more
about video game creation and guys that
are inspired the guy left his own
company I mean actually he left the
company Peter Jackson's company that was
making Lord of the Rings to make his own
video game he's amazing so if you
haven't of course please check out I
believe it was ILP 97 with Derek Riley
the creator the CEO of on Aurora 44 and
the creator of the game ashen that is on
PC and the Xbox check that out if you
guys have missed it but that's all I got
everybody enjoy we will be back next
week deep diving and breaking more stuff
down on the last word man all right
we'll have a good one everybody and we
we'll see you in the next one